two it's
Monday right yeah it's Monday yes sir I
had to catch I was like wait it is
Monday and I'll tell you what else it's
beautiful outside yes yes yes not a
raincloud in sight here in La happy to
announce it let me give you the full
weather report sit here at the top of
the show thanks everyone for watching by
the way here's your 10-day
forecast uh brought to you by the
streamy no brought to you by stamps.com
thank you to stamps.com for sponsoring
us today this is your stamps.com weather
report who we love God do we love him uh
here's your 10-day weather report from
me Ethan Klein the weather guy according
to streamy you just take a screenshot I
mean what do you want from me here this
is the weather in Los Angeles I don't
know how helpful that is any of you but
I mean hey tell me what city you you
live in I'll I'll Google the weather
there there too sure and you can take a
screenshot what's the weather like in
Albuquerque today good question weather
in
Albuquerque New Mexico just to be clear
as opposed to where New
[Music]
Mexico Albuquerque New Mexico 10day we
are looking like um a little it's
interesting actually a little chilly I
mean today you got a little scorcher at
81 but look over on th wow the tie is 51
that is a whiplash you're going to want
to wear a coat that's a 20° swing that
is actually pretty incredible oh that's
wonderful you would that's a 30° swing
my friend getting almost down to
freezing temperatures is that so that
would never happen here I mean that is
really a dramatic shift I have to say
the people of Albuquerque uh make sure
you got your winter apparel Tedy
fresh.com lots of outerwear there bundle
up New Mexico shout out Al we love him
shout out we love him jacket off a lot
of um a lot of requests coming through
for other cities uh in the chat what do
you got what are we feeling guys uh
let's see the first one Montreal
Montreal Canada what's it looking like
all right I didn't say I said America
only I saw Boston I saw Boston Boston
Boston Massachusetts let get Boston
weather okay here we go get your get
your uh phones ready oh my goodness
Boston it's raining wow it's a rainy day
in Boston
it's a rainy day out here in Boston stay
off slides people good news Saturday you
got a stormy week coming up but by
Saturday should be clearing up the sun
coming out there you go Bob's your uncle
take a
screenshot fantastic all right I'll do
Montreal I'm curious what the weather is
in Sweden oh it's that I am curious that
too Montreal it's cold it's rainy I mean
what the hell you guys it's
miserable uh snow on Saturday I guess
I'll look at Stockholm cuz that's the
only City I can think of Stockholm
weather let's see ooh dude is this what
Winter's like there oh my God even
winter fall uh yes yeah start winter
yeah every every single freaking
day wow that's nothing that what is
that like freezing it's not freezing oh
that's not even freezing dude oh my God
that's a warm fall yeah no it's lots of
rain though here I'll tell you in in
Celsius it's been snowing you see that
let me see that's not too bad that's not
too bad that's that's a good weather
t-shirt we don't need heat I know um but
that's a I don't think this is like a
once in a decade type of rain in la like
a whole week of rain yeah there's a
reason there's a reason there's a a
what's it called seasonal depression in
Sweden yeah you really
just yeah stay inside for half the year
well guys wherever you are I hope the
weather is beautiful and uh I love to
Google all your cities but uh just I'll
tell you this cool trick just go to
Google type your city and weather and
then pretty good uh
technology guys my throat is
up I did a CO test I did a CO test okay
I don't feel sick it's just and it was
positive yes I forgot that I didn't
mention that
surprise I strategically left the
results out
but I had a good well I can't say I had
a good weekend actually can't say that
at all we I was going to have a good
weekend on Saturday we had this uh whole
family day planned with the
boys and we were getting I was I went to
do an errand right before we left and 10
minutes out Ela calls me and goes you
have to come back immediately because
Bruce got super
injured injured yeah oh no so he so they
were playing and Teddy pushed him and
like there's this sharp
metal there's a table with sharp metal
edges which is I hate that table
we finally threw it the
out but he fell and
slammed in it right here and
uh so we went to we had to go to the ER
and he had three stitches Stitch poor
bru he's okay though he's okay yeah he's
a person so it begins with the siblings
my sister and I used to each other
up all the time we were kids when I
think about how crazy my sister and I
used to fight it's like we should have
been arrested like it was insane it's
scary for the most part they're good but
Teddy sometimes he just yeah because
Bruce I mean he doesn't speak that good
yet so teddy gets frustrated sometimes
when he's annoying him but
what
what what that's what you said when you
were drun say it again it's that bro
what the that's what we were all
saying when you were saying but there's
no context I don't know what it say you
were I think speaking like Bruce it is
Bruce your Bruce I don't know that it
works though Zach yeah without context
it just sounds like some kind of weird
grunt play it
again it's
is it pitched is it slow slow down no
it's not yes it is yes it is I'm my hand
of God it's not play it it's no shot do
you want to pull up find the time stamp
to the episode okay no way it sounds
like that of the 12h hour how long was
that episode it was like it was only
like eight and look up a a fix word yeah
that might be a challenge I'm going to
find it I think you were just looking
away from mic I think that's what
happened like you were saying it away
from the mic and that's why it sounds
all
distorted just saying damn this Up's
going on 2 million views baby um that's
really cool that's s wow um so it
actually was horrible we went to the
hospital we had to go to the ER we went
to Urgent Care they're like we don't
take kids I was
like what we don't do pediatrics here
the I was like the yeah no
that's what they told us I was like okay
that's cool good think kids never get
sick so then we had to go to the
emergency
room and it was we were there for like 5
hours at least the worst part was they
tried first to glue it
shut and so we had to hold him down this
poor kid restrain
him and it must have been really painful
because he was really fighting they
glued it shut and then it didn't
work so then we had to do it again with
the
stitches you
know but by the second one but on the
stitches they they actually G they give
kids um like benzos like a little benzo
shot in the nose to calm them down so
they so for the stitches he got a little
benzo shot in the nose and then he
chilled out did he start talking about
Chaos
Dragons no precisely no he may have
mentioned something about
dragons but um he's I guess most kids
fall asleep but Bruce was like he was
fighting it boy he hard animal he
wouldn't go to sleep but he was chill
they gave him a shot of uh lioc cane and
then they did the stitches but he was a
he's a great kid he took it like a champ
I'm glad to hear he's okay yeah he's
totally fine but he's got a pretty nice
little Shiner there mhm yeah but he he's
such a champ such a
Trooper uh AB did find the uh the clip
here oh go I so wait how did you
find it so fast well you know it's my
job you were just complaining though
just that good I forgot we had this
discussion before weeks ago and then
like Avery sent it to me weeks ago so I
went through mine and Avery's chat
history and I found it nice all right
Zach play yours it's
all you are joined yep you we have a
full list of all the members from
right now I'm
back what dude yours is
Ed that sounds to maybe sounds a little
muffled but what you it sounds like it's
pitched you did it a bunch of times I
I'm sure let me play let me
play that wait that did sound like it
hold on let me go
back it's now players it's it's the same
bro same thing bro all right all right
you're right you're
right does the crow taste good I mean
Ian it wasn't just me me and love were
yeah that was you guys need to
hear some more bro
yeah work on your listen have you ever
have you ever heard something
before all right
mystery apologies yeah apologies
apologies so um that was pretty crappy
but it's okay everyone's fine also
exciting news Teddy fresh is going to be
at complex con I don't know who goes to
that oh
oh but we're going to have a really
awesome Booth SL installation there that
Sam's been working on really hard and
the team has been working on and it's
going to look sick it's going to be
awesome give it up for
Sam yeah it
up who's s and uh we're going to be
announcing a really awesome
collaboration that we've been working on
there as well I wonder if I can say it I
don't think it matters now I mean it's
so I'm not the person
now you got to talk to your wife um talk
to the real boss let me call
her yeah why are you worried about my
wife I will say he's not wrong it's a
very very cool crossover that I'm pretty
stoked on Hell
yeah all will she answer careful with
that phone I don't know if it'll yeah
you're
almost save that for Tuesday
damn I can't get my wife to answer my
phone she's to busy she's
CEO I got cold for this damn
wife I think I could say it I mean it's
in a couple of weeks from now but here
I'm just going to say it
uh it's in a couple weeks how bad could
it be I don't I don't know how these
contct work if she didn't want me to
then she no it's not a contractual thing
I shouldn't say it I'm going to say
something I don't I probably shouldn't
say I mean comple con is uh November 18
I mean it's like 12
days where's Sam she she would know mhm
today I will St if listen if she want me
to say it she should answer the phone
this is on
her just saying the big collaboration my
friends high is 51 that is all my
friends and
family
[Music]
sorry whoops I guess I shouldn't have
said
that maybe that is too much of a hot
take about Israel
[Music]
Gaza no we were we weren't talking about
that uh here okay so that sorry I I said
too much I said too much let me let me
roll it back today my friends I'm here
and proud and happy to
announce a great collaboration that
we've worked with
uh lot I see people just got the
button I see that uh we've worked with a
lot of love
a lot of
excitement truly close and dear to our
hearts as it is I know all of
you it's a card game it's a big card
game a beautiful card
game it's magic the Gathering the card
game Sam
said okay what' she say don't say it she
said she was going to check she said
give me five minutes whatever don't tell
me you don't want me to say it
period E's got to keep it secret for me
but I want you that the designs are
sick I want everything D I'm not even
messing around everything's so sick
Roblox that would be cool maybe a future
One S San Rio is something you know on
the list yeah but it's magic the
Gathering and it's going to be
sick dude the art is like unmatched you
know and I think the team did such an
awesome job of mixing the brands into
some really beautiful clothing so magic
the Gathering oh the other cool thing is
at the booth where we
have like
uh they gave us like hundreds of booster
packs to give away oh that's cool
yeah they yeah it was really cool um we
shouldn't have said anything we could
have just played a draft could have just
just just sell them on eBay bro you just
open them all play so yeah we have a
huge giveaway of um booster packs too so
it's pretty cool nice that's pretty
sick yes
[Music]
[Applause]
sir so anyway um One More Time guys
dream nightmare remix competition the
deadline is
[Music]
Wednesday so make sure to get him in
I've seen some really good
ones I have seen some awesome
ones dude
mhm do you see that when you're not
there good chunk of the audience did not
understand that that that they thought
that whole thing was a mean just to be
clear that that was actually dream that
called clarify I understand at first
being confused but I talked to him for a
while yeah mhm and you were on his also
he was on live he was
live yeah he was live let's go he's a
good he's a good sport it was fun he has
a good sport about it I think the
sponsor idea is super
funny I I haven't hit him back just cuz
I don't know I feel weird taking money
from another Creator it's just I do
think it's a pretty funny idea to I
don't know I don't I just I don't I
wouldn't feel comfortable taking money
from it all right you
know um he could sponsor the stream the
steamies oh there's an idea brought to
you by yeah that okay that I could
consider we do need sponsors for that
event YouTube's hottest night people the
hottest night of the year for YouTube
um also I'm hoping to include him in the
uh the final judging
contest I don't want not the whole
tournament but like maybe on the finals
he can come in be a guest judge I like
that idea yeah
yeah yeah I see people in the people in
the chat wait that was real yes it was
real no not not trolling you guys it was
real to me damn it still real to me damn
it he was literally if you're doubting
me go on Twitch it's literally right
there on his twitch showann but anyway
so that's all the fun stuff happening
how was your guys's um weekends anything
to report it was pretty good it was
pretty good I uh I guess we probably
can't talk about it because people get
mad about spoilers but did you watch the
finale of Attack on Titan oh what the
it came out yeah it came out this
weekend did you watch it I haven't
watched it I
yeah so did you both watch it we uh me
and ab both watched it was it good he
liked it I gotta tell you I wasn't too
hot on it AB would like I don't think
ab's capable of criticizing that yeah
that's my favorite show I thought it was
good you're wearing a Theos shirt I am I
mean it wasn't terrible but interesting
I I can't say anything without spoilers
so yeah yeah but I did that this week so
did you love it AB or did you like like
it no I liked it a lot um I already read
the Manga so I knew how it was going to
end but they added eight pages to the
manga after they already ended it and I
was really hoping they wouldn't put that
in the anime and they they put it in the
credits and I was like ah you didn't
like the ending I I like the ending I
just when they added those eight pages I
wasn't really a fan of those you didn't
like the Lucas the Lucas Films director
cut with the right bar scene
mhm okay I look forward to watching it
definitely
um
it's damn it yeah there's all kinds of
little fun stories coming out oh God I
also forgot to tell you guys something
interesting as you guys know ant Sons
the chocolate company has they have been
leaning into the meme so hard
it's cracking me up but they are they're
clearly getting a ton of orders and I'm
happy for them I got to be honest I ate
all the candies all the chocolates and
then I was like the chocolates I act I
this has never happened to me before I
says I need more of those he's like
addicted and so I say never say this we
you know I've never said that I know
literally it's incredible and so I was
like Sam get a hold of him like the
least you could do is keep us chocolated
up like a weekly delivery I don't ask
for a lot but
damn uh but they they've been very funny
and uh very very kind and sweet but we
were talking in that segment about
another chocolate brand um compartes am
I saying it right yeah
okay Sam brought it in she said this is
my favorite
chocolate it was good it
wasn't not on the same level I mean we
can all agree on that I think so the
Compares people were
watching and then they reached out to
did he reach out to you Olivia not to
Sam so they reached out to Sam who's
here to join us right now and they said
okay that we want to come in and do
our chocolate with you guys so
they're coming in today at 3 to bring
their greatest spread andate here we
have perhaps a battle of the Titans
between
um what is it chocolate no the company
compartes and
an it's the the chocolate Wars are
heating up my friends and I couldn't be
more
excited I I'm you know I'm reserving my
judgment uh they're bringing in their
best and their finest and apparently the
person coming is their head choler so
this wow what CEO oh it's the CEO
everything wa oh this is the person yeah
oh that's the compart person okay cuz we
just got one son we didn't get them both
right the Second Son the exactly we've
got the Father the Son the holy
the studio we couldn't even get number
one with peace and love to my friend
Jeff he's not even in line to inherit
the
throne the chocolate from his from his
mom
Mark so I'm excited I thought that was
so funny and so cool that they reached
out
right dude the live stream is bugging
dude it goes from like 40,000 to 25,000
I saw that it keeps jumping up and down
by tens of thousands it must be bugged
you to what the okay cuz we that are
when I said I didn't like the attack on
Titan finale uh everyone bailed 20,000
people bailed unsub attack I loved it by
the way the the opinions expressed by
the crew are not mine for the
record so I just what time is it I mean
can we fast forward to three you
just want to do the chocolates I want
the chocolates me too I don't know what
happened that and bro awakened
something in me that I didn't know was
there it
was probably the best chocolate of ever
had I don't it was genuinely was like on
another level and for like no reason
they seem soen they seem so like chill
about it he's like yeah it's just Chef
Sandy I'm like Chef Sandy is a no no no
no no who is Chef Sandy and why she
magic yeah let's talk I need to know
more about Chef Sandy I agree with you
Ethan I'm I'm not a huge chocolate head
by any means that crazy that's some
everyday man dude it was
crazy um I woke up this morning and I
went and I was genuinely disappointed
that all the chocolates were gone I was
like man good morning I got to get back
on the chocolate game wait you were
going to eat chocolate in the
morning what is that shocking you I do
that yeah it have a bite of
chocolate what's wrong with that what do
you eat in the
morning uh I don't know like eggs or
something just chocolate doesn't sound
like a breakfast to me it's not a
breakfast Z I didn't say chocolate was
my breakfast I feel like I feel like I
I'd get scolded for that dude it's just
it from who I don't know you're a grown
ass family trauma you know brother
a sweet treat in the morning is
everything I take a little bite of
chocolate in the morning not every
morning but like you know what I'm going
to start doing that the system dude
yeah yeah I it's not something I do it
was just I love those chocolates so much
that um I saw someone else get it and
they I think there was a lot of orders
but someone or got it and they said it
was the best chocolate ever I don't
understand there's something going on
back there and they're way too
nonchalant about
it it's just a couple of Bros and Chef
Sandy it's like no they got schuma Limas
back there brother
some somebody studied this at like
willly Wonka mhm somebody stole Oompa
loomas and and they got like a cafe in
there too so some some chocolate with
that coffee oh yeah they have a barista
Next Level bro next level but we'll see
you know I don't want to glaze them up
too bad because we have the kartes folks
M coming in big time and and let's be
real depending on how much chocolate
compartes brings and leaves is
definitely going to affect my opinion
about them cuz I will say this about
Jeff Mark Mark hm whatever you guys know
what I'm talking about Mark he brought
in a ton of chocolates and we were all
stoked I don't know if he I don't know
if he he may have done it on accident he
just grab and leave so he took all
the chocolates with him when he left
he's dead to me I was like dude I wanted
that why'd you bring it and then
that's like taking a are you sure he had
more yeah I thought he I remember him
walk go to go go to him walking off he
had a bag of chocolate in his hand I saw
him put everything back in the back I
was like bro you're not going to leave
that I saw him walk out like man maybe
he just thought he was cleaning up his
mess he's cleaning up after himself hell
no dude he might have been on autopilot
but yeah but it's like you know you go
to a party and you bring a bottle of
wine and then like half of it's left and
then you take it home like I'm sorry
dude that's just not how it works or the
Seinfeld marble rise situation you know
right so I was you know we'll see
compart days if you're watching now
stock up right cuz that's going to be
huge they have like the cereal milk
candy bar that looks so good to me
compartes yeah it's like one of their
one of their best sellers I wasn't crazy
about their bars really I'm hoping that
their Artisan chocolates are more up
that they get you up for the challenge
well I can't forget they got to put it
in their glove comparte man and bring it
over Man glove comparte yeah hopefully
they got more than that here is um uh
Mark
Jeff here is Jeff dude we got him
red-handed dude look at this okay here
he
is hold
on oh hold on got to
unmute guys here he is taking the
chocolate bag two with him how do we
know
there
is taking out but how do you know
Dan and even at the end and we could
prove this in the video there was a
moment where he's like we can keep doing
more and then we're like nah I guess
we'll wrap it up cuz I was talking a
dream so he put those chocolates back in
his bag and he left it's true he also
had product placements like put them on
the desk put them back in the bag and
left I'm just saying you know he had
more of those six packs in there
bro you know did that's not even a
debate so I'm just saying if you are
watching Jeff Mark you can make it up to
us by bringing a whole bunch of
more Chate a
pallet that get get Chef sanding is a
get her ass to
work maybe he doesn't like dream it's
true he's a dream
hater you're
not not no chocolate in the in the idea
with oh is this another time stamp of
the
evidence oh no so if you go back to
before at
217 you sent me the same Tim stamp no no
I sent you a screenshot but then because
I'm using three monitors it sent all my
monitors so give me one sec I know why
he's resending it right now okay so here
we're getting video evidence of him
having chocolates putting them in the
bag and exiting the podcast with the
chocolates we actually have CCTV of him
leaving with a bag too so it don't make
us stalks ourselves but I will show it
here so that's habiscus honey oh
no
comment ity jelly yeah jelly I'm being a
little
dramatic
so this is awesome oh
super cool for you to come out and share
this with and so yeah and we do so for
the holidays we're doing new flavors so
you know that is that box right there
all those boxes on the table and he's
got like I think five or six new flavors
for the holidays that we releasing we're
also working with amazing so we to
partner up with with artist there was a
point where he brought some out and was
like we could do
more oops so we're with an artist
actually from vent yeah there's
this there it is okay
I've said my
piece so compartes we look to you to the
chocolate arms race but I man I'm
excited people in chat saying what if it
was just
jellies it wasn't I know y all I know
you all want to be Mark apologist here
today I just think there's a lot of
unknowns here I agree they were not
jellies they were unopened packs it
could have been the unopened jelly
palette they don't do one palette I even
asked I said can I get a whole thing of
fudge ones that I love he says no right
he says you have to go into the store
I've thought about this a lot I tried to
give him any out I could imagine but I
couldn't I couldn't find him a plausible
excuse so what else we got um uh what we
got probably is an ad for stamps.com all
right so after the
ad I'll talk about the title
which is this girl Brett Cooper who is
like she's Ben
Shapiro and when I say that I'm not
talking about her attitude although she
is also a conservative ship bag but she
is literally Ben shipiro
in drag or something like this is just
not really sure what how the did
they find her did they do a bench bar
lookalike contest and just hire the girl
who looked the most like him like where
do you find someone that looks like Ben
Shiro do you see
it it's unreal it's very very
strange so there it is
Nightmare I don't I don't want to be
crass but like if they and I I'm sure
and Ben's happily married so I'm not
this is just hypothetical but if they
mingled in coidus that would be an
interesting is that pairing would it be
just masturbation basically bu in
inbreeding is that what you're saying oh
God yeah that would be the child from
that would just have no genetic
diversity I don't want to see the
science if if the science is right I
don't if the science is wrong then why
does it feels so right people saying
isn't that his sister no no dude looks
just like her no relation
allegedly she's just someone else yeah
who they happen to hire she more like
him than his actual sister yeah cuz
maybe we didn't make that clear she
works for Ben Shapiro daily wire right
so not just like another commentator
that happens to look like him also don't
get us wrong she's beautiful that's I
should say that looks better as a
girl and somehow this is this isn't like
and me insulting her look she she is
very pretty yeah totally like
objectively yeah but it's more slight
against Ben than her mhm somehow it's
Ben yifi Queen he could pull hard if he
is there a picture of them together does
that exist I just dropped it oh wait no
this is him and his real sister no above
that oh they look even more I see
more some she's super short BR isn't
Ben's uh sister is she no I have a
theory though they're strangers go ahead
no relation dude I think I think cloning
has something to do with this I think
they were like we need uh like shapir is
just like how can I employ myself it's
like starting to get into like cloning
so he made a clone of himself they says
we need another bench sparow he makes us
so much money but we can't have another
bench SP so we need a female
right yeah and that is how Brett Cooper
was born dude look at the one I just I
just sent too that one you can really
see it okay oh my God you guys stop
taking photos together I don't like
it I just ain't right that's
cloning Ben looks kind of uh and
just for comparison here's Ben with his
actual sister who she does look like him
but yeah you can see that they're
related but I don't know if you threw
the other girl in here you would assume
all three of them are related I hate
that people always say
[Music]
l
yeah I I you know here's here's what
happened I thought I shouldn't say it
but I knew I could button it so I gave
it a shot intrusive thought I gave it a
shot and you guys did
laugh but it was so out of pocket was
crazy
was that funny AB or too much I'm sorry
I was listening back what was that oh
you didn't even hear it oh you didn't
hear it probably for the best I heard it
the first time I didn't hear what you
said though right
now yeah never mind was it did was it
offensive or funny it was funny cuz I me
it's us obviously I knew you weren't
saying that yeah it's a joke all right
let's do an
ad anyway and then we'll talk about this
thank you thank you to our wonderful
graci this supportive sponsor that we
love I am talking of course about stamp
stom let's look let's go let's
go stamps.com is helping a million plus
businesses get ahead of the holiday
shopping how are they doing it well to
start you can do have the con the
convenience of the post office office at
your home you sit at your house you sign
up for stamps.com they send you a
digital
scale okay then you take the package you
put it on the scale it tells you the
exact weight and so you print out the
exact postage boom you put it on then
this is where it's great you can
schedule a pickup they will come to your
house you could drop it in a at a drop
off point mailbox whatever you don't
have to go to the freaking post office
dude and but that's not even the best
part if you can believe
that I
can't the discounts that you get are
insane 84% off USPS and UPS rates Jesus
what yeah how does that even make sense
big of a discount they have a huge
carrier discount because they have such
a massive clientele that they're able to
negotiate the prices lower huh which I
didn't know was a thing before Teddy
fresh we we had to do that too with with
ups and stuff cuz if you just go send a
package just one I mean the the rates
are
nuts out of control no way to run a
business yeah so 84% off up to 84% off
USPS and UPS rates come
[Applause]
on they also automatically tell you the
cheapest and fastest shipping option so
you're going to you're going to know
exactly what you're getting you're going
to know you're getting the best price
and you're not going to have to go to
the freaking post office most
importantly they're a great company they
got a great reputation and they've been
around and I don't know if you know this
but Ali Dan's girlfriend loves
stamps.com yeah you know about that I
was about to bring up the fact that uh I
think my girlfriend uh uses this service
and has years so convenient it's so
convenient she can do it all from home
she got a little she sells her art she
sells her art it all happens on the
scale you you put it on the thing it
goes prints out a label you slap it on
the envelope hand it to the mailman Bob
your uncle bye literally telling me how
easy it is the other day before stamp do
you remember going to the post office
what that's like I mean it's just a crap
shoot like you never know what's going
to happen it's hassle city am I right
worse worse Hassel Metropolis H hassle
doesn't describe oh it's a catastrophe
City 25 years stamps.com has been
indispensable for over a million
businesses guys get access to USPS and
UPS Services right for your computer day
or night no traffic no waiting but
here's the best part guys we got a
deal give your business the gift of
stamps.com so your mailing and shipping
is covered this holiday season sign up
at stamps.com
h3v for special offer that includes a
4-week trial plus free postage what and
at digital scale no long-term commitment
or contracts just go to stamps.com
sl3 thank you to stamps.com for
supporting our show thank you thank you
[Music]
play it
Kenny K
G sending postages was never so
sexy I thought you were doing something
else
oh no no I was doing a
letter calm
[Music]
down all right
so let's talk about
Brett let's talk about bretty boy so
yeah um this has not Ben Shapiro
related and then like how can
you it's not it's bad enough it's weird
enough that she's a conservative
commentator
but the fact that she works for the
daily wire why are there not more
conspiracy theories about
this why we talking about qinon when
this shit's out there Brett
Cooper it's not
right all right with that being said
let's take it a let's look at a watch
here so it's called h3's audience turns
on
him and um the biggest thrust of course
comes from
um this that I hear all the time Jordan
Peterson's uh prophetic tweet
about just you wait Ethan they're going
to come for you next the mob and so
again I'm not sure what cancelled means
anymore
because I mean you could characterize it
as people disagreeing with me and
getting
upset but I don't know what you mean by
canceled because I'm
clearly I'm still standing
I'm still standing yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah so like I don't even know what
that
means but let's watch she'll explain go
ahead uh
Ben
Ben oh here's the Tweet she shows it so
I'll just I'll let her explain comment
section I'm Brett Cooper so I think we
all know by now that the more you give
into woke cancel culture fueled Politics
the higher standard they will hold you
to because if you give them even an inch
they will take a mile and we are
currently seeing this play out with one
of the big I love that she they can't
even identify it's just they it's just
they them out there man I'll tell you
what man they are coming the Royal
day biggest YouTubers out there Ethan
kleene also known as girl I have lost
weight I
resent so true girl you look amazing
up can I get some respect here in
the weight loss Community as age3 he
went from having a comedic runcha
YouTube channel where he didn't care
about offending people it was pretty
apolitical it was just all about him and
his personality to being the leader of
cancelling people online and now that's
me baby the leader that is a nice title
Ethan Klein leader of cancel culture I'm
the
Vanguard I'm coming for all you don't
you disagree with me cuz I'm they and
they is
coming now he is facing the wrath of his
own creation due to expressing his own
feelings about the Israel Palestine
conflict and we are going to talk about
that today before we do though make sure
that you like this video subscribe to
this channel if youve not already and
ring that also just a reminder she
usually gets like 250,000 per video she
got a big old juicer out of this 860,000
so the H3 hate is you still got it I
still got it it's crazy it's kind of
after all these years it's kind of
amazing yeah wow that you could still
juice it like that it's kind of a vibe
to be honest yeah you know yo The View
count is crazy what is going on is your
chart just like jumping all over yeah
yeah no you sent me a photo of it well
it
doesn't the chart actually doesn't like
the bar graph doesn't reflect the
numbers that are showing oh
okay I I do see like big dips in and out
though I hope it's not the same problem
that it was for so
do do you see people saying it's
crashing I haven't seen that uh earlier
when we mentioned I actually did see
some people say that it was glitched out
for
them I just sent a picture you see how
it like has these
dips but it's not nearly as big as show
somebody said Ethan identifies as they
them now interesting point I am
they that notification Bell so you never
miss a comment section or uplock episode
for context Ethan and his wife hila are
Jewish I'm not sure if they are
practicing but they are my wife's name
out of your mouth whatever sorry Jewish
and hila is from Israel she did her few
years I button that
out what I'm just kidding Indie is
that's just wasn't funny yeah I mean
should I button out the button out the
discussion of the button out Israeli
Army her entire family is still there
and this Heritage is incredibly
important to them so for me Birthright
is this really weird thing from people
outside it's weird from inside it's
still weird there's Rich Jews in Europe
UK Canada US who give you know what I
should do just cuz I want to watch the
whole thing but this is somewhat
exhausting um let's just speed up the
playback a little bit like quarter you
know what I mean yeah then and then
she'll sound more like bench SP
too thank you that was I believe someone
else's J that tons of money to the state
of Israel for the purpose of bringing
young Jews on this trip trip to Israel
to connect with jewi this guy's just
yapping wait hold on why yeah it doesn't
sound any different let's go to 1.5 I
guess it's like the most glorified
version of gate.net I didn't care about
theistic thing I don't think anyone too
fast
right yeah is this a better viewing
experience just me pausing and changing
the playback I don't know I feel like
whatever it's actually slow it down I
think I we would have finished at the
same time now yeah all right free trip
to Israel something that I could never
afford and something that sounds really
great the soldiers Ela soldiers they
join after a couple days we've already
been there and there is this girl that
is tall and beautiful and she's
got these huge blue eyes like why are
you playing so much of my video
Brett I the first time I watched this I
forgot that I was watching her video and
I was just listening to the
story she played so much of it for no
damn reason she doesn't even comment on
it like what and she's got like black
hair that like is a crazy contrast to
her blue eyes and I'm I'm there like I'm
there like in the corner like minding my
own business and I'm like is anyone
seeing this is anyone seeing this
what is the point of playing all this
there isn't one it's so bizarre a l of
minute of uninterrupted story that she
doesn't comment on she just want uh
there isn't any went into the Holocaust
Museum and we're like um trying to peep
that out it's kind of incredible that
like you can just put in a random clip
for a minute and then nobody even thinks
about it I didn't know what compelled me
but I felt like that was an appropriate
time to approach you m something about
the Holocaust M was just like this this
is appropriate this is the right time to
say what up Y and like I said before
when he first started on YouTube okay so
what was her original point before
showing that all she go ahead she said
like here I got I'll play it it's very
important to them and then you go it's
it was so weird Birthright was so weird
Okay Jewish I'm not sure if they are
practicing but they are ethnically
Jewish and hila is from Israel she did
her few years in the Israeli Army her
entire family is still there and this
Heritage is incredibly important to them
so for me oh so this does not prove that
not even not even close you're like for
a minute you're like all they give you a
free trip sock I mean I'm pretty sure in
this video I was talking about how the
Zionism was super weird and weirded
me the out and like they had like a
mega rally for like Zionism and I just I
like stayed home sick that day cuz I
just didn't want to do it so
clearly and that's not to say that I
don't uh you know care about Israel yeah
but in terms of like trying to exemplify
how important Zionism is to me or
something right it's not really doing
that you said that they bring people
over there so that they move there but
you're like we actually tricked them
because she came back with me there you
go that's the thing to people who all
the Zionist accusations I'm a I'm an
anti-zionist I'm the only one
actually going
there I'm doing what y'all dream would
happen and so I'm here getting
that's so funny come on
man I should be getting an award from
you
that's crazy that's actually
very
funny
damn to say what up and like I said
before when he first started on YouTube
he was pretty apolitical he was just
making funny content and bringing on any
guest regardless of their politics for
example he once had on Jordan Peterson
who he spoke very highly of like it was
a very positive interview he was very
excited to have Jordan on just take a
look at these clips today's guest is the
great and wonderful and one of our
all-time favorite guests Dr okay so this
was like killer sound bite in
retrospect yeah true actually this is
like five six seven years old I mean six
six years it's from uh 2017 I believe
you've never changed your mind about
something over the period of six
years dummy this is cons the
conservative talking boy is so
relentlessly you cannot change your mind
mind if you ever change your mind you
are wrong and you're a phony actually
too you may not how many shitty people
has her boss bench airo had on over the
years Russell bran was on his show six
years ago right well they probably does
that mean what does that mean cuz he's
part of their Network Now isn't he right
he's not on daily wire no no I mean he's
in that ecosystem but which one is Ben
though now I'm
confused I think it's this one yeah so
he so she's taller than Ben that doesn't
surprise
me golly there that's a that's a bunch
of good-look
GS
goly beautiful
ladies anyway go on
Brett and by the way this is like pre
benzo
hellscape Twitter psychotic uh Jordan
Peterson who went to rehab in
Russia right this was before the preco
the whole coma uh Saga before apple
cider destroyed him so like this truly
is a totally different dude in my
opinion there are things that I learned
about him that I didn't know at the time
as I've become more politically involved
and aware basically just how dishonest
the whole
trans uh the way he framed that the hate
speech about trans people was and
I mean so he's changed up your and I've
learned more about him exactly is that
okay with you Brett acknowledge
that I
mean like Brett you know at the
beginning of World War II or no before
World War II let's say you know you
might have looked at Adolf Hitler and
been like he this guy's just a strong
leader he's got you know he's driving
the economy he's getting things done at
the years later you might have a lot
different opinion about I don't know if
you would but some people
would yes you might like him more I
don't know yes so I'm say this is just
my point I know it's dramatic but you
can change your mind about somebody
thank you
Jordan Jord Peterson who has graced us
with his presence The Great and
Wonderful Jordan Peterson there's a lot
of people that would not call Jordan
that anymore because now they hate him
they me one of them dummy right wait
yeah
right thanks for playing that out there
think he is problematic like everybody
in Canada
does I love by the way epic if you need
a Hallmark of dog gutter
level content just look for like
reaction memes edited in throughout that
triggers me I think that's my uh pet
peeve was she even born when that movie
came
out oh you think she's young yeah she's
22 so no wa she's 22 didn't that movie
come out she looks like ay old man 2000
or 99 uh 99 no no no you're right 99 99
I love that movie by the way such a good
movie Yo she looks like a 50-year-old
man and she's 22 uh Brett uh sorry Ben
is 39 39 whatever same thing still old
yeah it is the same thing you know you
being that same age right we often point
out he's old as what a
loser
sucks to be
Ben we all handle hate of one kind or
another how do you handle it like
knowing that there's people out there
who have never met you don't know you at
all but they they just hate your guts
yeah well I mean I you know of I do
recognize an irony here of the people
that hate my guts that don't know
anything about me is basically you MH
and all of your homies it's it's
conservatives you know so it depends on
who they are it depends on they are an
academic or a journalist of some repute
and they go after me with without
warrant I'll go after them and call them
out because I think if they're
professors it's like look how sane he
looked back then though this man is not
in a joker
suit you know he's done his hair is like
kind of modestly done back
uhuh he's straight up Too Faced now man
absolutely he's in his villain Arc you
can't even deny it Brett
get your act together you've got a
position ofth stop touching your eyes by
the way
yeah all right you're not with me
247 so it is what it is and it ain't
what it
ain't
um what was I
saying bench Bureau two face now he's
Jordan is Jordan is what what I say oh
yeah minutes into this podcast episode
he's asking about how he handles hate
online there's hope there's people out
there that don't like you that hate you
for no reason but over the last few
years Ethan has fallen into the angry
left side of the media and he has
basically become the icon for canceling
people online and ridiculing right-wing
conservative personalities specifically
and he went from saying all of these
wonderful things about Jordan Peterson
you know graciously inviting him onto
his podcast say how do you deal with the
hate there's people out there who hate
you being genuinely interested in what
he has to say to deleting the podcast
with Jordan because he regretted it
because it was so problematic and making
fun of him on a daily basis like this
he's better and that that's not toxic
masculine what are we going to do
without men you know real dragon of
chaos is actually what should we be
without men these are all different guys
who keep notes of All Enemies doesn't
even sound like Jord it sounds like Dan
oh you just burned yourself he literally
is Kermit the Frog you just complimented
my impression you don't even know it
holy delete a possible things it
doesn't even sound like Jordan it sounds
like Kermit the how could she be unaware
that that's what everybody says about
him there couldn't be a higher
compliment my impression frankly without
men their penises hang to the left it's
not a good impression and it's just
simply not a good luck but any okay
first of all I will sit here and take
your ridicule I will take your
slander and your mischaracterizations
but what I won't take is you talking
on my
impression you're you're just a dragon
of chaos the female energy it's it's
really something they can both be
nurturing like a mother is naturally but
also they can become chaos agents
destructive they use men they just want
money and shelter I did not put my dick
anywhere near my door and God bless him
for it that's what's so great of having
a
you can decide what goes in
it absolutely he kind of did say that
for
btim and but men they got to put it in
stuff you know how hard it is to put it
in vagina it's a lot easier to block
it and that's what men deal with on a
daily basis she doesn't
understand
Prime you know a little hole it's easy
to protect Duty could do it with your
hand or some other foreign object to
Chast belt but a
penis for sexual
kick my grandmother's
pubes soft and
luxurious I took a snip of them saved
them in my
bedside I sniff them every night gives
me
[Music]
comfort her genital region was exposed
dimly it had the
appearance
hair all right
no anyway that is just one example of
what Ethan's content has turned into and
the complete 180 shift that he
personally has had but recently
something interesting happened because
Ethan has been getting a taste of his
own medicine he has been getting dragged
through the mud by his own audience for
his defense of Israel and his Israeli
family surprise surprise funny how that
always works now all of this started
when his co-host for the podcast Assan
perer who we all know and love Assan
perer had a debate with him about Israel
and Palestine and hisan was taking the
side of Palestine in the Ethan was
obviously defending Israel and the vital
from their Progressive leftwing audience
has been so intense that Ethan has
started distancing himself from his
friend and from his co-host H watch this
Ethan his leftover is done for good um I
wouldn't say it's done for good I
love so much that she's reacting
to a clip of me with Kinetic Sand like
there has to be people watching her
video that are just Boomers that don't
understand what the is going on
right now on their screen and they're
probably staring at it too they're
probably
mesmerized how could they and that that
wasn't even ours you said love somebody
else no it's a gr F account um yeah he
does really so funny dude oh
I said is that it's you know I
would like to take a pause from it
that's all at one hand people are saying
Ethan someone take Ethan's phone and so
here this is me relinquishing my phone
I'm saying I taking a break with peace
and love my fear with the show is just
basically that um for the for the time
being I'm just staring at the same
is that there's going to be a lot of
more episodes that are going to make
people really angry and it's going to be
really upsetting maybe I'm casting too
broad of a brush when I talk about like
the reception and stuff but there is a
lot of people that take my I don't
really even know what I did other than
like try to talk about how horrible
Hamas is but that that enough turns
people into just the meanest I've ever
seen them and it's just not worth it for
me and my family there's a million
people everywhere talking about it so I
don't feel that I need to add my voice
to it right now you see my face you've
watched watched enough
Brett she's just locked in on the
connetic standand too so many Boomers
pay attention I mean at this point this
might be my
video and I might be I see the amount of
views you got there bre boy BR girl bre
boy ow so I'm just saying you know keep
the clips to a minimum there he looks
completely broken so obviously he does
not look like he's doing completely BR
that clip was pretty mild to me right
that was the best she could find as a
result that I am in shambled cancelled
Beyond repair friendship ruined and
doing really badly which to be fair
Brett yeah you clearly don't know me but
I always look like I'm doing very badly
you see looks completely broken so
obvious completely broken yeah it might
be true but it's pretty normal yeah but
it's consistent yeah look like he's
doing well they had that one episode
that one debate and everything fell
apart because of how angry people got
which is incredibly iron because he goes
after people all the time online and
tries to cancel them all the time online
and suddenly he is facing that he's like
oh man this really sucks it's like yeah
it's kind of how it is online these days
can you get what does she mean that I'm
cancelling people I I don't know it
just we've been in this cancel
culture discourse for four or five years
now and the longer it goes on just the
stupider it gets I mean nobody's
cancelled Ethan's fine yeah the show
Show's fine it's like unaffected pretty
much
is she like defending James Charles or
Ryan Colleen who who she defending her I
don't know yeah but it's the the meaning
of the damn cancel culture doesn't mean
anything it means nothing but there is
something good coming up here the more
people in your group in your community
have created this culture where there
cannot be any discourse where there
can't be any Nuance or complexity or
personal experiences that are informing
your thoughts about a very very
difficult huge global conflict there's
no room for that anymore and I'm sorry
but it's your people that have caused
that and you are 100% facing the
consequences of that oh no all right dmy
let's put a pin in that and go over to
your to your um your your benef or I
would say your source
code it's like what do you call the
first clone like the original human and
like a line of Clone Army you know I
guess it would be like patient zero type
thing or like patient zero yeah so once
again uh Brett now according to Brett
I've been fully cancel Sadam Hussein
invaded Kuwait by my
audience and uh there can be no Nuance
takes on the left well here's exhibit a
dummy and I hope you see this
two weeks ago look at the like this look
at the like ratio on Benny boy's
this is Ben saying that he thinks
America should support Israel and now
there's like a whole conservative
movement I guess where people just want
to be isolationists and not help any
country ever including Ukraine so
they're just out on everything and they
hate this take
actually yep I mean that's like a 60%
down vote is he canceled I don't know
let's read the comments fresh and fits
at the top you know that's
bad by the way so now that I'm up you're
down if your audience has enough overlap
with fresh and fit where people are
actually up voting their comment that is
dangerous in scary times female vaginas
are disgusting is this really their
account let me make
sure no it's a fake one oh it's a fake
one I knew it because it said fresh and
fit Miami right fit fresh yeah it's not
real fit fresh anyway it is a upvoted
comment it says Ben we should do
absolutely nothing to help Ukraine also
Ben help Israel at all costs facts don't
care about your feelings unless it's
about Israel right Ben the answer always
is that America has to spend its own
resources to take care of another
country where our own country cres it's
absolutely absurd Ben spel Israel can
carry itself it doesn't need America
also Ben America help
Israel fellow Americans your comments
and response to this video are fantastic
it is just an onslaught Israel could
take care of herself bench pero
2016 you're on your own Ben good luck in
the
IDF these are his people this didn't
even get a lot of views so this isn't
this has 230,000 so it's not like wide
reaching phenomenon here where these are
your people right I just when I got to
that part that was it came to mind cuz I
had been kind of keeping tabs on Benny
boy over there and I knew that his
audience was not vibing on a lot of what
he had to say so and we didn't we didn't
get a down vote ratio that bad anywhere
well here I'll here's the two
controversial episodes that I was
apparently canceled for according to um
Brett Cooper so the original
discussion Israel vers Gaza has a 92.5
like ratio pretty good pretty average
compared to Ben's which is
40 uh here's me having responding to ELA
conspiracy theories about her being
lying about her IDF service which was
pretty unhinged I got into some I w't
say unhinge but we gotten a heated back
and forth with the chat 89% dislike or I
mean like scroll down a little bit oh
never mind Ian's got it 89% like but
once again Benny boy right which is like
bad for us but not that bad and you know
what I hate to kick someone when they're
down but go ahead show it no I don't
you I am inside your walls B yeah what
they said that
guy Ben
Ben um
and you know what's funny talking about
Council culture again the reason that
I'm cancelled at
all that had the probably the worst
effect on our sponsors on the show is
because of Ben Shapiro y being a
little baby boy about my hilarious
and poignant joke about something that
happened to the Jews in the midst of
World War II
right which by the way this same people
in your comment
section goof saying good luck in the IDF
Ben are the same neo-nazis that
you've been courting your whole
career right and that's why I
said I'm you're first and I'm right
behind you okay that's my point
Ben so who's doing cancel culture yeah
that literally the only the only example
in the last several years of an actual
cancellation where we we suffered
serious consequences for something was
because of Ben Shapiro literally Ben
Shapiro and conservatives losing their
clutching their pearls because
of a Jew making
a frankly it wasn't even like
a it it was a useful analogy like I
understand that it was kind of
mean-spirited it was harsh it was very
harsh harsh it was harsh absolutely but
it wasn't like I just said it just to be
mean it was a it was you know yes you
were making a point why the by the
way when I say some like
that I get banned for a week right but
then when somebody uploads a video a
cartoon of ela killing Palestinian kids
that stays up because it's
artistic awesome Yep some
so uh go on brick Cooper tell
me more about how I'm being eaten by the
left because they disagree with this one
take oh what what happened what oh no
how terrible that's just that's just
awful how you can you what's happening
can you who is
this spit it out thank you for the
reaction meme I know how to feel about
that now oh that was
funny oh no somebody said liberals eat
themselves constantly you can't just
have a semi- middle ground opinion
anymore you have to be super radical one
more
time mine was 92% like Ben o not good as
something as mild as saying us should
help Israel which I think is extremely
uncontroversial in
America yeah I mean especially amongst I
pick up from one of the comments that I
think at one point he said that nukes
were on the table which that's pretty
psychotic to say that is psycho that's
crazy mean what was the can you I want
to see that can you time stamp that I'll
see if I can find it I didn't actually
hear that I just saw one of the comments
refer to him saying that in the video
and that was why they were commenting so
um if he did say that that's pretty
psychotic let's to have support right
now very true another person said Ethan
becomes aware of Hanan yes I his who's
his he did and just overall I think he
oh by the way girl good job pulling that
Minecraft avatar with zero likes that
was super poignant look at this Matt 990
Avatar
logo zero lik Ethan's becoming aware of
his sin awesome dude cool I
think he did and just overall I think he
is a bit shell shocked and just very
surprised that his audience would turn
on him you should be because you have
also turned on people you know how it
works but you know he is experiencing
that what do you mean my audience turned
on me some people
disagreed like you guys are the ones
that
characterize
disagreements as cancellations right and
then you say that liberals or whatever
are the ones that can't have
conversations it's so
ironic oh what happened I'm
searching the transcript of that video
for nuke and I'm not seeing anything so
I don't want to I don't want to slander
Ben here no I think I think I'm seeing
it did you welcome back to I didn't find
it but I saw some people talking about
it so let me see these time stamps here
I believe an individual citizen in this
country has a right to own a nuclear
warhead dude how does anybody Listen to
Tim after he said
that I'm working on my own nuclear power
program actually my are you I'm just
starting a new Tik Tok I'm digging a a
basement level a dungeon level and I'm
working on a nuclear reactor down there
how you enriching I I I was able to
acquire some enriched uranium from some
friends in Russia not a big deal oh very
cool Klein Noble yeah Klein Noble
kally calling me a Zionist Pig Mass
murdering genocidal freak wa did I did I
watch this where were we I accidentally
closed
it absolutely of Jews get abandoned by
their their own comrades another person
said red pills are hard to swallow but
they fix what else you is that what you
think girl
really I need to take a red pill because
some people disagreed with me where's
your belly button
Ben cuz he's a clone oh now streaming on
daily wire very cool benjiro
XY now do one with Brett behind him wait
this is the woman oh wait no that's Ben
okay I'm not seeing Ben mention it in
this video it seems this comment is
taking what he said as him referring to
nukes by saying responding with
everything in their Arsenal that's a
stretch well yeah I mean I don't Strate
he's he's doing the same strategic
ambiguity that Israel does exactly he
knows the play though I mean I I I think
that's a yeah he's in line with official
policy
there yeah just like Ruff greens can fix
what ails your dogs because you might
not realize it I I saw this I was like
yo I need to get on these canceled ads
cuz you know these don't get
cuz they're such pieces of crap
free rough
greens get your dog some of that good
magga we getg green like the green new
deal I'm not buying that
you're stupid my dog only eats the
best
magga meals around I didn't my dog it's
it's made by good old Maga folks churned
in like my in a basement with a bunch
goods and think it's edible I think the
dogs seem to like it I don't know if
it's got any kind of nutrition or
nothing but ain't none of them died
yet they seem real happy and
healthy what is this soy they're
selling uh vegetarian dog food is that
what that is that really what it is like
soy alert rough green I might be I might
be uh reaching uh let's see I'm looking
it up your dog oh let me say this for
the record do not go harass her
sponsor this is not what I'm doing this
is not what I'm meaning to do this is
not what I want you guys to do just
don't do that that's you know what I
mean we don't need to do that don't go
write them an email and say dumb
just don't okay we're just having
fun here we're goofing off not trying
look like it's maybe is vegetarian dog
food pretty
surprising you just told me I need take
the red pill and you're buying
vegetarian food for dogs I mean at least
it just shows a bunch of vegetables on
the packaging by the way maybe there is
also feeding dogs vegetarian diet is
super unhealthy I've never done anything
word with my dogs I remember some vegans
were trying to do it and their dogs like
are not
healthy it feels like in their mission
statement that their dog food is dead
food rough greens provides all the live
in all caps nutrients you need to bring
your dog's food back to life check the
nutritional do it what's the I'm not
seeing anything about meat in it so it
does seem ingred but they're not like
explicitly calling it here sweet potato
sunflower seeds parsley Blackberry wheat
grass spinach prote broccoli barley
grass chiaki mushrooms is this a
supplement yeah maybe you're supposed to
use May supplement that doesn't sound
like oh yeah they refer to it as a
supplement so I guess you're supposed to
mix this in with their normal dog food
got it still soy
my do e
veggies food and diet might be the root
cause of their health
is like Ethan is 5766 my dog and you
will find out how amazing Ruff greens is
just like Ethan is finding out what
happens when you go against the woke mom
like this commenter said guess he's
finding out he certainly is another
person said a red pill moment that
should have never been needed and listen
I don't want to celebrate by the way I'm
sitting here before you
all
live telling you I have not been red
pilled can you if they don't can't take
my word for it then who's they're like
yo Ethan got red pilled I'm still I know
I didn't I'm telling you right
now this Ben Shapiro costume
winner here no matter what she's can say
is not going to convince me that I got
red
pilled you should definitely get a DNA
test
though cuz you are 100% that
that's the lyric right yes cuz I I
don't want to I would never call her
that no you did an incredible job with
the L thank you great this situation
because obviously this man is hurting
his family is hurting his wife is
hurting It's just sad overall but it
didn't have to be this way because Ethan
was warned about this by none other than
Jordan Peterson and Not only was he
warned about this but he turned around
and he mocked that warning so when Ethan
really started becoming radical and
became her trigger happy he deleted that
podcast episod he one thing I learned
through all this is I am definitely not
radical I'm like pretty vanilla in terms
of lefties leftist yeah with Jordan
Peterson and dragged his name through
the mud online with his audience and in
response Jordan Peterson gave him a very
friendly preview of the road that he was
going down he said also I should warn
you that those who engage in cancel
culture generally live to regret it I'm
not going to come after you except
politely in this Twitter stream but the
chickens will definitely come home to
roost you will be held to Higher and
Higher and soon impossible to maintain
ethical standards by the very mob you
currently wish to please then you will
make a mistake and they will devour you
with Glee please take this warning
seriously I liked you I I here I sit
before you with 41,000 live viewers
fully cancelled I've lost everything
yeah how so people have been reading
this to me for so long for how long does
he have for that to to be right cuz I
mean you can't be on the internet
without like going through controversy
especially when you're talking about
politics and all the I do so what
how exactly do we get an expir
expiration date are we talking like till
I'm 80 till I'm dead no just yeah for
the rest of your life just for the rest
of anybody gets mad at you Jordan
Peterson was right he gave me the
sacrifice brand
yeah the from berserk I can't get rid of
right yeah yeah yeah you've been branded
you have been Sac marked for sa you're
the struggler now
but of course Ethan did not take it
seriously at all somebody responded to
this from Jordan and said somebody needs
to make a Jordan Peterson I Told You So
meme already another person said this is
almost predictable the woke demands 100%
compliance or else Ethan one sec the
woke demand 100% compliance or else uh
one more what was the like ratio in our
Israel Gaza one 93 is 93% likes that's
Saddam Hussein invaded Kuwait president
one sec if we go to Ben
from 2 weeks ago this is what America
must do hey dummy take a look at your
own backyard 14,000 likes
dislikes that's brutal man talk about
talk about not being able
to be your own man I mean especially
coming from Ben I mean you literally
can't be your own man you look like Ben
Shapiro no here you guys are Ben Shapiro
XY the first generation of clones
that's scary that's so
true that's so true where's their belly
button I've never seen them ever whoa
that's true damn Brett's got some now
getting yeah he looks they look
good they exercise that's that's conser
part of conservative Doctrine right the
or else part absolutely correct Ethan
not only refused to take this advice
from Jordan but he also mocked and
ridiculed Jordan for even giving him the
advice this is epic he says also I
should warn you that those who engage in
Council culture generally live to regret
it please take this warning
seriously I like you yeah I'm sure it
was much
easier I'm a funny guy the words of
Jimmy
Lee what the why did you show that
doing like an Emperor Palpatine thing to
make fun of him and do your Jordan
impression and throw this out of
proportion say it was ridiculous when
you were not being attacked talk about
blowing no definitely not talk about
blowing it out of proportion man this
man just sent me one tweet and
y'all can't stop talking about
it
dummies but look what happened but this
is the conservative grift is so
easy you guys
860,000 views which is three four times
more three times more than she usually
gets and like
I've heard this exact argument made a
thousand times it's like a right of
passage it's just milking those views
baby
mhm you did make a mistake in the eyes
of the mob you are being attacked the
chickens have come home mad you made fun
of this some people are mad at me is
that what you mean like it's you you
sound like a child you sound so
infantile canceled is like what happened
to like Kevin spy
yeah that man is cancelled okay canceled
is like what happened to um Army Hammer
that dude crystalia they're gone from
public life MH these are a fraction of
my audience disagreeing with me like you
are so infantile you're so childish this
is how you perceive conversations
happening are you this pathetic like
holy you know cancel is what's
going to happen when the qinon people
figure out that you guys are actually
doing cloning
experiments you know what I
mean don't go to the pizza parlor
tomorrow right I like you
guys he has no pizza
experience and for pointing it out
correctly and you're facing the
consequences thank you Zach smart yeah
we're good we know and Jordan was right
as he usually is are we surprised by any
of this absolutely not any anyway she
just goes on it's pretty annoying but or
pretty worthless yeah so there's BR
Cooper so what do we think welcome back
to the com to the title was Jordan
Peterson right he was right yeah oh okay
he'll be right he has a long time to be
right yeah I think by the time that I my
life is done and over and I It's Time to
Say Goodbye I'm sure
that he'll be he'll be able to be right
by then if not already if not already
we'll figure it out man the barricades
he's right though there's going to be a
lot of roosters roosting chickens
roosting his prediction was basically
this I predict that a fraction of your
audience will eventually get mad at you
for something you said
mhm clearly you've never heard of
chestnuts roasting on an open
fire yeah there it is there's the the
rising
[Music]
star controversy was bigger than this
dude yeah definitely you got more people
mad that I got for the chestnut
yeah D I got raded for Chestnut although
once again I did Issue a 10 out of 10
apology which is worth
men right the first ever and only
perfect score apology by uh psychology
in Seattle like
great tomorrow Ohio votes on adding
abortion rights and other reproductive
Health to the state constitution if F1
passes abortion remains legal and H
could you please remind ohans to vote
Yes yes ohans
go
vote tomorrow's election day we should
look it up and make sure that that's not
a troll getting our audience to vote for
an abortion ban I just don't know enough
about read the ballot you know
what I mean don't don't just go vote
issue one vote for the one that is
keeping abortion legal go to the
polls okay go they're not trolling issue
one is is a is a yes go vote ohans out
there Pokemon go to the
polls by the way her most recent video
from yesterday a day ago 990,000 views
Jordan Peterson was right 870,000
Jen Z hates sex
scenes H where' you see that three days
ago that video gen Z hates sex scenes oh
Hollywood needs to stop welcome back to
the comments section the same outfit how
many are you making a day oh hold the
phone she's a Content
Queen don't hate on my girl for
productivity the uh it's the quartering
uh method where you just knock out like
15 a day so here she's wearing a
different so these two were shot on the
same day yeah at least change your shirt
jeez it's a little corny I think welcome
back to the comment section I'm Brett
Cooper today we are talking about
something that we have talked about a
lot on the show which is how our society
and our media just pushes sex and
sexuality so hard these days and the
demographic for that sex and sexuality
keeps getting younger and younger which
is the real problematic problem I don't
like it but I don't like it I don't like
it I don't like it from the education
system soci I don't like it that's so
funny because I wasn't sure how to feel
but after that who by the way that I
forget what's his name Chris Chris Evans
he's like a massive lib by the way so
kind of ironic I don't like it I always
see him tweeting out some lib mhm I
don't like which I agree with by the way
just to be clear media to porn
consumption it truly is everywhere but
Per a recent study young adults in
America might not be as interested in it
okay whatever just turn off the porn
then lady if you don't want to watch it
I don't know what to tell you blah blah
blah I know tons of people that love
porn what Ian but oh Z silenced me sorry
I downloaded some reaction gifts too
just to add some you know oh you did oh
we got a couple of the classics you know
we got like this guy oh hell yeah that's
a good one that one's so funny can you
please include those throughout yeah
that's going to be a big big big big
contributor so people know how to feel
about like here let me set this up yeah
I'll be like did you guys see this Brett
Cooper video I mean what the
heck and anyway
she couldn't be more wrong I mean she
said Jordan Peterson predicted I'd be
cancelled but come
on anyway nice she clearly is not
familiar with my content because people
get mad at me all the
time oh for real sometimes I feel that
way just like backing away that s me
right now yeah anyway
I love gamer Subs let me take a
sip
perfect wow I feel like we're
communicating on a whole new level yeah
this is great delete me from this
conversation I cannot believe that Ben
Shapiro is Brett Cooper in a wig
right that's so true that is so cool
right now isn't
it well anyway enough of about Brett
Cooper I can't wait for the chocolate
segment oh yeah oh that was good you see
it does it's really good I understand
why she does it now it's not like a
crutch or anything at all it's not like
she's not confident in her own content
that she's got to use pieces of
other people's content to convince you
the audience she's so insecure by the
way she's got to convince you
guys that her content is better than it
is right Ian
I ran out of gifts a Sam's telling me
the chocolate person is here though oh
bring them in D that's up I'm just
wasting time for
that I am so jazzed up right
now if there's any other chocolate
you're a chocolate fiend huh you big on
the chalk dude I've never been that big
into chocolate I'll be honest like
compared to other like desserts
chocolate is like Universal it's like s
Tierre you
dude it's chocolate I know that yeah
it's like one of our greatest as far as
Humanity goes mhm I think you could go
across all cultures of the
world everybody Lov it's just there's
nothing like it now I like CH I'm not
saying that I like love love
love love chocolate or anything but it
is a fascinating food let me put it this
way when you were a kid you go to the
ice cream shop vanilla or chocolate
which one you taking I wouldn't get
either but I won't get chocolate
chocolate ice cream is boring I
agree chocolate you said you wouldn't
get either I would get mint and chip
that's my vibe oh you said chocolate ice
cream is horrible no I said boring okay
boring I eat it give me a cup I'll eat
it I'm just saying it's well the mint
and Chip there's chocolate in there so
that's yeah it's a chocolate approval
but like
dude I mean can you name any other food
that's consumed widely and enjoyed maybe
rice like ricei yeah rice chicken poor
chickens
man is there anyone that doesn't eat
chicken those poor Sun Zig Gans no
everyone
does feel so bad say is there somebody
that don't eat chicken yeah I don't know
if there's country that don't eat
chicken they don't eat chicken me
neither I know not I didn't say are
there people in the world that don't eat
chicken are there countries where it's
like not the norm for people to eat
chicken you know that's where chickens
want to move to yeah chicken countries
where people eat chicken like I don't
know in Tibet they're Buddhist they
they're vegetarians right I don't know
uh yeah well and in India in general
there's a lot of vegetarians though um
uh yes okay stop right there Dan okay
sorry oh my okay hold on as you I'm just
going to use the bathroom as you're
setting up and I'll come right back but
I'm excited thank you what's your name
jonath so here just you could say hi so
everyone knows this is Jonathan this is
the Rival chocolate here hey
Jonathan so much chocolate and it's all
being left right
here all right I'll be right back man is
hyped uh are there any uh cultures that
don't eat chicken here's a a quora
thread about that exact question let's
find out what it has to say yes there
are some cultures and religions that do
not consume chicken but eat other types
of meat here are some examples Hinduism
many Hindus avoid eating beef and pork
right we knew about that
however they make consume other meat
such as chicken lamb or fish that's such
a non-answer bro what the I didn't
ask beef and pork Janes don't there
here's a Reddit thread from
2013 September 11th
2013 never forget some cultures don't
eat pork and other beef is there any
culture that doesn't eat chicken here we
go uh many archaeologists believe that
chickens were the first domesticated not
for eating but for C fighting what oh
God the poor don't eat them but animal
abuse right right right chicken I mean
this is some random Reddit comment so
don't don't take
that that's 100% real but no I'm going
to I'm the Reddit I'm the Reddit
research Queen
animal oh their link was to Smithsonian
Magazine and that's page can't be found
so I can't dig in more about the
anthropology of chicken fighting
back in the day
um yeah I think uh I think Ethan might
be right I'm not seeing any specific
cultures where like chicken's a a no no
so there you go there you go no safe
place I love chicken you love chicken
shout out all the chickens I just ate a
bunch of chicken D and katsu curry and
rice and stuff like
that H yeah I think we we got to eat
chicken on things Thanksgiving we got to
keep the turkeys
alive all right but every I feel like
every other day is chicken Thanksgiving
you know I I hate turkey I hate
turkey
kill wait you want to kill the turkey
and you won't even eat it I won't even
eat it I just I'm
scared we got to keep them alive and I'm
the bird guy those turkeys what the
wow yeah that is big you are the
bird guy what what why I mean what's up
with Fu scary look at a tur can we
google a turkey face real quick can show
the audience what a turkey look like
scary I they scare me you
know look at a turkey there's a lot of
people that are afraid of birds or
various type of birds and that's
something that's just never clicked for
me I don't get
it uh yeah they react like like I don't
like spiders and a lot of creepy crawly
bugs and so I get it dude at but uh I
just never understood why people are
afraid of birds like birds are cool
I mean turkeys are kind of ugly I'll
give you that they're demons
dude definitely ugly eat it and play it
oh fun okay can we get a shot of the T
the spread out here uh yeah here you
want to fire up the so um camera what
first of all yes are you what's your
position at the compart I am the owner
you are the owner I'm the owner yeah I
see your blinged out and some sick ass
Prada I am I do chocolate for for lots
of Brands so uh but yeah I'm the owner
but I'm also the the chocolate maker and
I also design all the packaging and the
packaging is like it's a onean show yeah
it is it's like it's a oneman show but
we have 30 people that make the
chocolate which is amazing so how many
employees do you have how big is the
company we have about 30 people that
make it and we used to have four stores
before the pandemic here in La we had
like Brentwood Sentry City uh Hollywood
and then we closed them all and now our
chocolates just online and like at
Nordstroms and Bloomingdales and things
like that okay so similar did you know
about antson do you know about them you
know I didn't know about them until I
watched your show because I got so many
texts of people saying like they're
trying compartes on H3 and I was like
first of
all whatever I said about compartes at
the time we're going to put it aside
you're wait until you can put it aside
thank you with the thank you I like I
saw that you liked a lot of the bars in
the beginning too and I was like okay I
have to bring him the best of the best
stuff right and we've got like do you
like peanut butter I'll yes okay like we
have so much stuff we have our dut bar
too but like look at this this is our
zodiac chocolate box it's it's so so
freaking cool so you do the what does it
mean that you make the chocolate what
does that mean so I do the recipes and I
also do the packaging so all because I
think people eat with their eyes first
right so like if you're giving a gift
you want it to look really cool and
amazing mhm so we have like that and
then we have all these bars which we
have like the Donut Bar I want to pass
them around for everybody but like first
can we do the peanut butter cups because
like yeah they're like freaking so we
have dark and milk chocolate peanut
butter cups so whichever you like oo
those look they're they're so so
we make our peanut butter with honey
instead of sugar and it's like super
bring over
here here's peanut butter pops all right
I'm going to do oh that's heavy too got
some to it good it's so good hold on and
then I'm look at that so it's a
giant uh yeah homemade peanut butter cup
and that crunch that's what you look for
when you eat chocolate right but like
the inside is full with the sticky honey
peanut butter situation it's like that's
crazy that's crazy Sam and I love that
Sam loved Compares too before which is
like amazing well she yeah oh my God
they look she said it's her favorite
chocolate she brought it here thank you
hold on I got to eat this m so that
peanut butter was like named the best
peanut butter in La really did you sell
the peanut butter by your I used to sell
it by the jar but then I was it was like
really hard to I had to choose make
chocolates or sell peanut butter you
didn't have enough no it was just like
annoying in the I see I see it so I was
like I have to put it in chocolate
instead oh that's
PR I do like how crunchy the chocolate
is that's snack it's a nice texture yeah
the snap is like what most like people
that are educated in chocolate they're
looking for is that snap on the outside
yeah that means the chocolate's at the
right temper which is like makes it
crunchy makes it shiny you can see like
oh I hear everybody snapping around the
studio that's see that's what I like
that's like music to my ears the Anson's
ones was very soft that's what I kind of
noticed about it the chocolate layer was
like really delicate yeah I think most
people look for the snap which is The
Temper we're Snappers here yeah we're
Snappers and like I always think like
elevated Nostalgia right it's like
people love peanut butter cups how can I
make them better or this is like do you
like nuts or no I like it yeah I like
the only thing I don't like is jelly
filling I know that first of all I don't
make any jellies no jellies dude why is
that why is that to be honest with you I
don't like jelly either Fu dude okay I
really don't some serious chocolate
clout right there I like I don't like
peanut butter and jelly sandwich I'm
just like a peanut butter only oh
that's super good that's like a g that's
that's a gourmet Turtle so that has
caramel nuts and then sea
salt oh hell kicking your
feet yeah you guys come take it's those
are like so again it's like a turtle is
caramel and nuts and people always know
that from different like bars you could
buy at the grocery store whatever but I
was like how can I make that better
that's clever I like that yeah and put
the sea salt on top mhm m i i noticed
you're going for the dark ones do you
like dark better than milk I do yeah and
your thoughts on that as a choler you
know we make like 300 different types of
chocolate I do you make your chocolate
we make everything from scratch
everything like the peanut butter the
chocolate the caramel everything is done
by hand you must have a really nice or
interesting facility where you I wish
you would come now you're going to have
to go to like two chocolate batteries
but but I think you guys should come it
would be amazing or bring your kids
because we used to do like kids birth
parties oh really yeah and I would teach
kids how to make it and they could like
decorate their own chocolate and stuff
like
that so what's the process of making
chocolate for you guys from scratch so
we basically for example like this Tic
Tac Toe thing I'll show you right so
this is like this is so cool this is the
edible tic tac toe if you want to try it
but basically it's kind of made upside
down I don't want to touch your
chocolate so if you take one out and
show I can explain how it's made oh that
those are beautiful that's super cool
too because you can like literally play
it as a game so it's like why would you
give boring chocolate when you get
chocolate that looks like this so true
you just totally imped Anson's whole
business
model so you see that snap salted
caramel on the outside so the way we
make it is you make like the Shelf first
that's
Snappy Dan are you trying it too that's
so good that one's
crazy that one has so you make the shell
first then we inject it with caramel and
then we top it and then you turn it over
and that's how the chocolate is actually
made so it's kind of made upside down
from the way that you're do you hand you
hand make each one everyone holy smokes
yeah we've been in business since 1950
so it was like um compartes has become
sort of like
instagrammable trendy brand clearly
you're not 80 so
who's you know that are before you yeah
it's a family business so my dad did it
and my grandma did it so it's a third
generation yeah we've been in La the
whole time but like Marilyn Monroe used
to shop at compartes Frank Sinatra it's
like this cool Hollywood history um and
then I grew up just kind of making
chocolate and it was kind of like a
boardwalk chocolate shop like you'd see
at a fair or you know at any little
small town and I wanted to like
modernize it and make it cool
um what's the process though you guys
buy like a bunch of cocoa beans from
somewhere do you get them from all over
you have one source yeah we don't do
bean to Bar chocolate so we it's kind of
like what you were watching with Anson
so um we melt down the chocolate and
then well we have our specific certain
blend of chocolate so we have like three
different types of dark chocolate we use
and then we have a milk and a white and
what's interesting about our white do
you I know you're not a big white fan
but I Sam I know you were excited to try
this too I like white really this is a
cornbread chocolate bar that's the other
oh cornbread is amaz yeah like
somebody gassed back there who was that
this is I'm I even want to eat some of
this cuz I love cornbread like I do
everything that do you eat chocolate
every day like a whole bunch or you over
it I you know what I eat a lot of
chocolate I don't eat like I eat
chocolate and salad cuz it's all about
balance right at the end of the day is
there chocolate in the counter do you
eat it there's a lot of chocolate yeah
and if I go on vacation or like I go
somewhere I always bring my chocolate
like I can't I get this is so
interesting isn't it I know Stam gonna
go crazy for that so this like this most
people say they don't like white
chocolate but our white chocolate in
particular is kind of special I think um
so how do you go about finding a good
chocolate maker with the beans and they
make the whole chocolate yeah so who are
these people I'm basically tasting it
all the time and I'm always trying to
improve the recipe so it's it's like
people send me different samples of
chocolate from different countries so
chocolate grows in like the equatorial
regions so you have Venezuela Ecuador
Peru a lot of South American countries
that grow chocolate uh or cocoa beans um
they also grow it in Hawaii now too okay
so like that's my dream is to like have
my own cocoa Farm in Hawaii and like
grow it myself what's stopping you
making all the chocolate here in Hawaii
there's too much to do and Hawaii I feel
like I'd get bored in Hawaii well it is
an island it is an island I'm see I'm
I'm even going to eat this this is a
corn it's so good oh yeah that what do
we think that is the most amazing thing
I've ever had about W this is my new
favorite flavor oh oh my God this is so
good I love this are we are you what are
you eating Sam the cornbread one yes
cornbread you guys want to try the donut
one too I can't even tell what you're
holding you mutilated the thing look at
what Sam's holding up but it's just the
bag okay that that is the most amazing
thing I think I've ever had in my life
wow the like texture the crunch of the
Corn so good so good oh donut and coffee
that's our number one best seller this
is our number one bestselling flavor the
dut and coffee bar try wait I want to
give you guys some too you ever think
about doing like a Golden Ticket thing
just for fun yeah but I heard that like
they have the lock down on you can't do
it you you cannot say we can't say that
we're not allowed can you call it like a
golden Platinum ticket oh wait hold
on do you
hold the phone hold on hold
it that's really
good that's really good there's I love
that there's like literally chunks of
donuts in it so it's a nice flavor combo
yeah I go to like oh my God doughnut
shops around in LA and I get fresh
donuts and we literally like pull them
apart and throw them in the chocolate if
you look at our Instagram or a Tik Tok
you can see them making it we do so much
on like Tik Tok and Instagram of the
videos of showing how it's made um and
it's literally milk chocolate doughnut
pieces and coffee grinds M wow that's
crazy that one's really good there
that's the cool thing about compartes is
cuz we have so many flavors it's like
almost there's something for everyone
you guys are always making new flavors
and yeah like like there's Dali which is
the Indian New Year now yeah um and so
we did like this duali box that has holy
smoke that has and I designed this
really cool packaging so it has like
mango Lassie coconut ginger it's like
all Indian flavors we have a Hanukkah
chocolate collection we have a Christmas
we all different flavor yeah well well
well don't hold out oh yeah I I love
India I love India too you know God
bless them God bless great culture over
there Ian Could you um on Jonathan shot
turn off the uh the background just for
a second just cuz that packaging is so
nice but it's like we have you on the
green screen so all the Green in that
packaging is getting uh keyed out and
looks all fuzzy do this one just one
second oh there we go look at that
oh my God it's so nice that's so good
that's the Indian one so it has like
kind of unique flavors yes what is that
one it's so good there's like a little
guide in the top of the cuz we cuz
literally like we make a lot of small
batch things that are like a drop it
should say it in there what does it say
from left oh okay what is that pear
cardamom pear cardamom that one's so
good that is so good I love the
flavors of the
Indian uh flavors mixed with the
chocolate I expected and really good
that and that's what's so cool cuz we do
like we actually did um I would say this
one wasn't that good we did a Vita
chocolate collab that was filled with
valvita cheese that sounds gross that
sounds disgusting they did a lot of
tastings online about it so hold on
people didn't love it did when you do
something like that do you feel like I
shouldn't have done that or it's it's
such fun and I mean that one in
particular was like they had it on like
the Today Show in Good Morning America
and I was like great people are going to
our website they know it's cheese and
chocolate they know it's probably not
going to taste good and so you know uh
but we do like we have an avocado
chocolate bar we have a rosé wine
chocolate bar that's like kind of what
we're known for is these wacky flavors
the bars and and then like now really
the boxes have become this big thing
like I know oh fruit chocolate I have no
jellies but I do have something that I
wanted to see what you think about I'll
try it okay Apple I got a little anxious
when you mentioned fruit chocolate I
know but this is like this at least you
could see you know those boxes of
chocolate that you get and you can't you
don't know what's on the inside right so
like at least this you know you're
getting the fruit that's awesome so if
you don't like the fruit you could skip
these right I love that I love
that did you guys try the Indian ones
the yeah the The diali Collection it's
so good so like which ones of this would
you have okay oh damn that's heavy so we
got like Boi or orange
kiwi the most popular BL babbe yeah the
most popular is like the orange slices
orange peels and apricots I'm going to
try the
blueberries oh my tooth
almost but like it's not a jelly I like
this it's not a jelly it's a fruit it's
like a dried fruit yeah so you know what
you're getting you don't just bite it in
and have a random love love what do you
think Sam I haven't tried this one yet
but you love the cornbread did you guys
try the doughnut one back there yeah the
donut great dude really great we have so
many too we have gingerbread we have
strawberry shortcake I love that you
brought so much you heard me I heard you
but I was already planning to because
like I would not go and I I I don't take
I'm this is for you I'm leaving it I
would always leave it not only did you
say that but I would never take it
that's why that's why I'm always like
the the guest at the dinner party that
people like to invite even though they
might not really want to invite me
they're probably inviting me for the
chocolate for the chocolate yeah it's
like you ever think that they know what
they got you ever think that maybe
that's true I think it probably is true
yeah but I'm like yeah just invite me
your event I'll bring the chocolate
that's awesome just so anyone that wants
to I'll I'll go you know so you guys
don't have brick and mortar stores
anymore we don't have brick and mortar
but we're online so we're at
lach of green tea or if they like coffee
you get this and that and the other I
think that Indian one was my favorite it
was so nice you want another one I got
it over
here I'm starting to get murder which
one oh the raspberry cluster this is my
favorite of the day and and our
chocolate by the way just so everyone
knows it's the only chocolate to ever
get a perfect score from bone
Appetit really and it's I know yeah
thank you go yeah wow that that was like
a big deal for me cuz I never went to
Chocolate school or anything I just made
chocolate like the way that I would want
to make it so what chocolate got a
perfect score the truffles truffles yeah
which is that's what I
need I can't believe you're saving the
truffles for last saving the best for
last this is why this is why we're
here this is this well this is this is
all those painted colorful ones right
holy so this got a perfect score
these truffles the only chocolate to
ever get a perfect score and this has
also like been on I know know we talked
about Oprah on Friday but this is the
most favored Oprah thing of all
chocolate I saw that this morning oah
loves this chocolate do you know how
many points are in those or no that's a
10 Weight Watchers points yeah do you
know what's funny Weight Watchers had
asked me to do do like a collab that's
and I was scared to know the points so I
didn't want to do it I didn't want
anyone to cap why did they do that don't
that's not a good collab Oprah no
offense the calorie thing like what I
would try is either pistachio I could
tell you like I know all the flavors off
off the top which is the 10 out of 10
flavor um I mean it was the whole box oh
was the box was rated
okay it it was the whole box whole Bo
yeah the only chocolate to get a perfect
store from bone Appetit and like
Consumer Reports best chocolate I was
watching on Friday and I was thinking
we've got a lot of cred I want you have
I want you guys to see the best of the
best so which one should I do here you
says this one's pachio that's coconut
the one above it's pistachio which I
love is there just a plain chocolate
truffle hold on I don't want to I want
to give you the the best plain chocolate
truffle which I have somewhere here it
is this isand new too this is like
really
special I brought so much stuff I love
dude there is really so much stuff aome
Sam Sam didn't you say you you've been
preparing for this all day I you really
I I'm smart I didn't eat either I was
like making the for you guys and eating
it just to make sure cuz I was like
you're going to taste it yeah like I
made these about an hour ago that's so
crazy like I'm the chef and the
chocolate here and the you know because
it's my own business so it's like really
important that everything's amazing W
it's my reputation that is amazing do
you make it at the store yes cool was it
hard to tr oh these look these are puff
powdery Little Devils that's like a
traditional rolled truffle and if you
guys didn't know the reason why truffles
are called truffles is because they look
like a truffle
mushroom right and that's why they have
that powder oh there there those
are so decadent they're so
good that's like a pure dark chocolate
super dark truffle little hazelnut
that's a 10 no hazelnut really yeah
maybe like the powder is making you
think hazelnut
m I like the powder it's so interesting
yeah it's you don't see them like this
no it that's kind of the traditional way
that they do it in Europe and stuff like
that my God but it's really decadent
it's like I was thinking why don't I
call them like blackout truffles because
like it's almost like you want to
blackout when you eat them they're so
they're so they're intense
so was it hard to transition
from having four stores to selling
online only you know it's been like the
best thing of my life actually I love
selling online because then like
everyone can buy it simp yeah we also
open we have some comparte stores in
Japan and I also just open a comparte
store in Dubai in the Dubai Mall really
and we ship like all over the world so I
know like if you have viewers in Canada
and Australia like we ship all over the
do it all over the place you guys are
international it was a serious operation
yeah we and we really take it seriously
like our shipping team you know I have
people that have worked for me for like
14 15 years worked with me and they they
every single like shipment that we do we
check the address to make sure that it's
not going to melt we add the ice packs
like we're very serious about it I
always I assumed for some reason that
this was all like machines and packaged
automatically and wrapped up and the
fact that yall are making it is really
surprising good and cool people think
that because it's like people see the
brand in a lot of places I mean this is
so cool this is brand new I just put
this on my website before I drove here
oh you did yeah so this is the first
like even the photo shoot was at my
house last night hell yeah what's in it
that's a beautiful box this is freaking
amazing I think of new Louis batons yeah
Lou be right it does this I think this
the coolest thing I've ever made look at
the so it's keying out it's keying out
cuz you're in front of a green screen oh
hit him with the bar right this is like
a a bar trunk wow the magnetic amazing
yeah this is such a good gift magnet
closer love those it's like you could I
mean it's so cool
right because I think like if you're
going to give someone a gift you want to
give them something that
W just just my girl with her confar
taking this woo That's So Posh it's Posh
right mhm it makes an impression how
much is this 200 bucks that's yeah with
16 bars inside 200 16 bars as hell how
much is a bar
$9.95 and and I could do I I would even
I would do an a an I would do an H3
viewer discount I have to app I have to
put it on right now before we I could
tell H3 loves compartes could be the
code good beautiful um this this box
is that's really special right like what
do you get for somebody that has
everything or like your grandparents or
your parents right thought to buy
chocolate you know but it is really a
nice gift but everyone loves
Chun a just chilling with my compartes
my wife and kids are going to be so
happy to see me they are aren't they I'm
going to be the hero tonight your kids
your your kids are going to love the
cial one who weren't you talking about
the Cal one I need to try it the cereal
one is so good that was like one of our
original and it's like compartes is
Nostalgia right like this bar is not is
not a bone Appetit like thing it's
supposed supposed to be creamy chocolate
and cereal it's decadent it's nostalgic
it's not like that serious let's see
this is the cereal bowl cereal bowl okay
so that has like Lucky Charms oh
marshmallows Corn
Flakes from them to use their cereal no
but if I put their name on it I would
need permission oh my God that's so cool
is magically delicious holy I M oh
my God holy mhm M so you guys go
and pick the M the marshmallows out we
do we have a we have a lady who one of
our Oompa loomas just like separated
them out and you know the new movie is
coming out right did you guys know that
the new willly Wonka with um with Timmy
Timmy shells yeah haven't we done enough
to that poor IP I know like isn't the
original the best it's one of the my
favorite movies ever yeah how can you
mess with the like there's no you can't
mess just leave the man alone I've seen
the trailer too and apparently it's a
musical and there are no songs in those
trailers which means oh are they bad
probably are we having a cat's moment
yeah I don't know why is there no music
in there so let me ask you this when did
you growing up did you always knew that
you were destined to be a choler because
of your family I you know I love
chocolate and I love art and I love
design and I love food so like this
allows me to have fun I think of like
almost art we do all these like drops
and new boxes and it's always like I
guess I get to continue to do new things
like the Zodiac one right it's like I
just I'm always thinking like what can I
do next and it allows me to be creative
and have freedom to do what I want so
it's almost like I feel like I'm an
artist but I'm a choler at the same time
right and but yeah I love chocolate like
that's the other thing who doesn't love
chocolate I do Dan Dan apparently he was
literally just hat saying I hate
chocolate I he's putting Dan hates
birthdays too he hates birthday that one
kind he hates capitalism I've been
eating I've been eating all the
chocolate man I'm eating the chocolate
no I like chocolate did anyone else try
did you guys try the orange slices or
orange peels there I don't think I could
bro I I just feel I think I just ate
like 20 chocolates you know I will say
I'm in the minority here where I don't
like chocolate peanut butter but those
peanut butter cups so good oh my
God this is so good Zach I love your
reactions I love your passion I love
food man what can I say oh what's what's
your hat what hat is that it's a Rolex
hat it's such a cool hat oh okay where'd
you get that why do you wear
that I'm in the club dude he a Rolex guy
now you are I didn't know I just I never
I didn't know to connect you and Rox
until I saw you in the house I don't I
don't know it's crazy it's a really
crazy thing yeah yeah he has a Rolex
does he yeah that is is baller yeah yeah
you can't see it on his tell us about it
Zach what model is it a Submariner date
uh 2015 is the year it was made 40 mm
stainless
steel I should make like a chocolate
watch a chocolate watch that you could
wear wouldn't that be cool wear that
right yeah you'd wear that that's a
cool what what's the origin story you're
saying you're the third generation yes
so originally how was what's the story
there with like uh matriarch or you said
your great grandmother or your
grandmother yeah my grandma so there was
Mr and Mrs comparte so that's where the
name came from comes from French uh
Italian Italian couple and they never
had any kids and so when they got older
they sold it to my grandma who was a
friend of theirs oh and then my family
bought it and to be honest with you it
was like this small business and my
family didn't want me to change anything
because it was like in business for so
many years and I wanted to make it cool
and updated and they didn't want to
spend any money so I started designing
the packaging myself because they
wouldn't hire a graphic designer and I
was like okay I'm going to learn
Photoshop or even like shooting stuff
for our Instagram page I just kind of
taught myself and uh when I was 21 I
bought the company from my family oh so
you are Mr compartes I'm the new Mr
compartes yeah wow that's interesting
yeah and I and I want to create like a
legacy I want to have this like I think
compart days should be a worldwide brand
a worldwide thing seems like you're on
your way you're doing good work to get
there yeah and I love it I love it so I
just want to like continue you dream
about chocolate ABS I have a book yeah
you have a dream book about chocolate
and I write down like ideas chocolate do
you ever get chocolate ideas in your
dreams tons of chocolate ideas like and
and I'm also chocolates yeah I'm also
always thinking like for
scum uh yeah I actually agree very much
with that quote don't don't you think
think like
was if you don't have the guide right if
you don't have the guide but we put the
guide in I didn't put the guide many
years ago and people would really
about it I
mean that's my one to hang up with c's
they don't put the guide in there
because you don't want to get jellies by
accident right you like Seas candy I
like the Bordeaux at Seas what's right
that's that's good um but I used to make
a Bordeaux and I thought mine was better
but I but it wasn't that popular what is
Bordeaux I don't know what that Bordeaux
is like a brown sugar walnut cream milk
Bordeaux oh these look
nice they're not as good as compartes
but of course of course not they
couldn't hand a chocolate they couldn't
hold a chocolate candle to it yeah but
but on our site I did did just put up
that chess that trunk thing one yes and
I'm also doing like a chocolate chest
set close the
trunk close the trunk you buy you buy a
certain amount of these boxes ahead of
time Y and then if you sell them you
just sold out yep exactly we also do
custom chocolate so we do like um I've
done like chocolate for Sonic the
Hedgehog Pokemon uh also do you guys
does anyone watch like League I don't
know if it's watched League of Legends
or Arcane there's this I watch League of
Legends all the time right do you watch
it or
play arcane's awesome Arcane y can't
wait a second I did a collaboration with
Arcane which was like these chocolate
bars and they sold out in 24 hours we
sold like 5,000 of each yeah and people
are trading them online for $100 each
and they're $9.95 what do they look like
what they have the Arcane characters on
them it's just like imprint like uh
stamped in like the packaging has Arcane
yeah but then the flavors I did were
like based on Arcane
people yes go ahead Zach you can finish
it all different flavors all different
flavors yes for Arcane yeah but it's
crazy that people are siging them for
100 bucks that
crazy um so how do you are your parents
are they like damn this are they giving
you that the props now right my Dad
gives me the props and he says he wants
to get back in he's like he's like I I
want to pay what you paid me and I'm
like no Dad sorry no no no uh you're
done Dad I'm done with I'm yeah you
don't ow I don't owe you anymore
dad you I do owe him Thanksgiving
chocolate and Christmas chocolate that's
it that was part of the contract and
he'd be lucky if you don't leave a bill
no he I I have to bring like 20 lb for
every family event wait that was in the
contract yeah like I bought the business
plus was in the contract chocolate for
Life yeah my dad's a smart guy what the
your dad is hustling you yeah he is he's
always and the chocolate he he's like
give me my 20 PBS I need gift chocolate
look like I mean where's that box that
peanut butter that huge box it's like
that times 20 this that's like a 2B
right there so it's like 10 of those and
he just Hoards them throughout the year
and eats them up yeah he gives it to his
Postman and his secretary and he gets
Social clout oh yeah he goes to all the
charity events in Beverly Hills with the
comperes smartart yeah he knows what
he's doing do you guys want to try some
more I think oh I mean I I have so much
stuff this is called can anyone eat more
chocolate yeah of course you this
is called girls are ready yeah I'm ready
this is the everything bar and it
literally has everything it's chocolate
and all the good stuff so it's dark milk
and white chocolate it's got potato
chips fretzels
brownies cake Marsh it's like a little
bit of everything I could pass it that
way was was uh yeah you could pass it
out I I think I'll die if I eat more
there's a s'mores bar which is really
cool nice I like s'mores and
this has my dogs on the back which is
really my dogs might not live forever
but they'll always live on in the
s'mores bar wait where are your dogs in
the s'mores bar see they're hidden at
the bottom there's like four little poor
little teddy bear teddy Teddy looking
dogs what the hecking dog down here yeah
like let's
see so oh down here uhhuh oh cute them
so you have four dogs I have four dogs
and what what are these called pomeran
Pomeranians you have four Pomeranians
yeah yeah and I put their pictures on a
lot of stuff like like this kind of this
holiday box with the foxes really kind
of like those are my dogs on there it's
personal to me cute um how old are they
I have a 17-year-old dog which is really
old yeah lucky yeah he's amazing uh and
then like not to bring the Vibes down
but my best friend my dog died recently
he was only five really yeah I just
wanted to bring the mood down a little
bit Yeah well have a piece of chocolate
that Mak of him is that is yeah he's my
best
butt we we could put his face on a
chocolate too that' be F that's what I
always say yeah we can honor him I know
my dogs won't live forever do you bring
your dogs to work no you're not allowed
by Health Department oh you can't hell
no you can't have and and dogs can't eat
chocolate yeah that's a that's a that's
like a thing like when I go home I wash
I scrub my nails to make sure that like
there's not any Chate I don't want a dog
heard that chocolate while bad for dogs
the danger is OV exaggerated a
bit one of my dogs do uh accidentally
ate a Crunch bar and I I was so pissed
yeah and they're small they're small but
you know why I was pissed cuz it didn't
eat
compartes I was so mad I'm like if my
get access to that my brother had a
Crunch bar in his pocket your
brother I know I was like why is my
brother cheating on me first of all with
a Crunch bar but second of all like if
my dog's going to eat any chocolate so
your dog should be part yeah it the dog
had to have the stomach pumped but I was
really I was really pissed cuz it wasn't
compartes do you don't pass out kartes
on Halloween you know if people would
come to my door I would love to you
don't get trick-or-treaters yeah I don't
get trick-or-treaters La is like kind of
you have to go to the right neighborhood
yeah to find them that's what Zach says
Zach has been talking about how La isn't
like Halloweeny anymore yeah dude I it
really isn't and I don't know why yeah
yeah it's a big city you got to you know
I mean you got to go where the people
are but I what I always say thought the
people were in La yeah I'd be so happy
if I was a kid and I got one of these at
the trick or treat right that would
be insane a Rice Krispy treat filled bar
or like a cookie butter one right so
what did your brother do uh my brother's
a trainer a personal trainer okay yeah
and so you guys are kind of at odds a
little bit there it sounds like you guys
are like competing forces in the world
oh no that's a good racket he's he's
creating uh clients for his brother
that's true that's actually a really
good point uh the funnel well I I that's
true I have a vegan organic chocolate
line that my brother like coins okay not
like his name's not on the packaging or
anything he couldn't he couldn't afford
to buy it well he he he told me I should
make a protein one and I do have one
with protein in it kind of a good idea
yeah and he does he's always like
where's my percent of the protein one
and I'm like Jordan you know chill chill
I'll send train business I'll take care
of the chocolate but the vegan one the
vegan line uh that we have is really
delicious M um and it's also like our
least
bestseller because people want doughnut
bars and cereal bars they don't want
beeg you know when you eat a hamburger
you know you're doing something
unhealthy you got to just go for it yeah
you have to go for it yeah when we used
to have our stores in La the biggest
thing was like people dressed in
Lululemon outfits m is that how you
pronounce it you guys know that's the
leggings right yeah yeah with like a
donut bar in one hand and a green
smoothie in the other it's
awesome that was like my biggest
customer wow so um wel I mean
congratulations on this amazing business
that you built up thank you what was it
like what was the trajectory of the
business when you took over from your
parents like how long did it take you or
how much growth did you experience since
that time you know I um I like have
invested in the business every year so I
don't take the money out and you know
buy a Lamborghini I
reinvest so I'll buy packaging one year
more Machinery the next year um we don't
have any conveyor belts either which
makes comperes very different uh
everything's done by hand are you anti-c
conveyor belt I'm so anti-c conveyor
belt and why is that everyone thinks I'm
nuts for being anti-c conveyor uh I like
to make it the oldfashioned way like the
way that I learned how to make it I
don't really want to update it I get
scared that if I change it it would like
the formula would be different or like
the flavor would be BR don't don't fix
it if it ain't broke don't fix it yeah
and I also think there's something nice
about doing it like the traditional way
that they've been doing it for all these
years right I don't want a robot making
compartes is that what the conveyor belt
means or is it just like they eat kind
of more ease of production I don't even
know what that means well here I'll show
you something interesting so our bars
cuz they have like the real ingredients
in them they're they're really chunky so
I don't know if you could see but
they're like this has the Rice Krispy
Treats in it yeah so I once bought a
conveyor
and my chocolate wouldn't go through the
conveyor belt because they're handmade
and their thicknesses vary oh so it all
it got screwed up and I took the
conveyor belt out and I I threw it in
the garbage yeah yeah cuz I couldn't it
can't do what humans can do no you can't
and and because they're like yeah cuz
they're cuz they're like real like it
doesn't understand the chunky right it
doesn't understand this this good stuff
apparently uh people are apologizing to
Mark you w over vegan chat apparently
there's a lot of vegans who are excited
we have so many vegan products on our
site because you know why good dark
chocolate by the way should be vegan
because dark chocolate shouldn't have
milk in it yeah but if you like go to
the grocery store cheap dark chocolate
they add in milk and stuff to kind of
water it down right uh but good dark
chocolate should be vegan like all those
fruits you guys were eating that's just
fruits and dark chocolate or we have
like nuts and dark ch so so how do you
get that creamy is it just yeah how do
you get that creamy kind of consisten
without milk or butter that is a Great
Smoky flavor yeah that good Smoky flavor
that good that good chocy uh it's the
cocoa butter so cocoa butter doesn't
actually it's not actually butter no it
cocoa butter is like actually the fat
from the chocolate beans so you process
the beans and you probably just press
them until the oils come out yeah I mean
I guess cocoa butter like that people
scrub on them is somehow related to the
the chocolate bean ones dude chocolate
is like miraculous does it you out like
the cocoa yeah it's the food of the Gods
it is it's so incredible people used to
use it as a currency I'd be a really
rich man yeah well I do too I get
invited to places for my chocolate um
but they also used to use it to
like psychedelic stuff right there was
like some you trip on Coco I think so I
don't want to tell anything tell us step
by step that would be a Google thing
endorsed by
compartes um but it so here's cocoa
butter there's cocoa butter so that's a
derivative of the chocolate beans and
that's what makes chocolate creamy and
like it's almost like avocado oil it's
all cocoa but so let's see how to make
cocoa butter I want to see that I'm
curious what's the
[Music]
process hello everyone welcome back
today recipe we are going to learn how
to make cocoa I'm just going to mute it
and we'll just take a look here so she's
starting with Coco CH makes sense I
liked her voice you do you want it back
calming it's actually lagging yeah it
was very calming right like Coco buttery
okay so we're stirring we're mixing
we're
boiling uh let's see her
commentary so after 2 to 3 hours you are
going to see that the water will reduce
the water is going to juice so keep
stering so that you don't burn your
butter so you keep stering so you st it
every 5 minutes okay so the Butter's
coming up to the top start to settle on
top so you can see tiny tiny oil on top
how do they get it so white though now
you can see the oil is floating on top
like Coco butter oh that looks nasty oh
I see it's just the fat oil on top
collect how long you got to cook
that I'm happy this is not what I do
yeah that's a whole different vertical
doesn't look as tasty that does not no
no asking question why is it that
chocolateers don't make their own
chocolate so CH chocolate processing
like from Bean to bar is a whole other
thing because they're taking the beans
and they're grinding it down and then
they're mixing it with sugar and that's
how you get what we know as chocolate um
but you have to have totally different
equipment and machinery and then you
also have to roast the chocolate and
there's a whole kind of process to it um
I think most people don't do that
because of how much time it takes me
it's like a whole another business but
there are people that specialize in just
that too so I think what we know as
chocolate is kind of mixing all these
ingredients things together like
caramels and peanut butter and stuff
like that but there are people that do
just like pure chocolate and they might
get it from like your farm or then my
farm and it would taste different
because we've fed our trees cuz it comes
from from a tree yeah like chocolate
they say chocolate's healthy because it
grows on a tree that's the other crazy
thing about a chocolate it's healthy it
is healthy chocolate is has like some of
the most potent
antioxidants of any food that's why
Oprah has her one piece a day of
Compares God bless her God B yeah God
bless Oprah I mean that's like I hope
yeah yeah she's been really supportive
of compart I really appre I really
appreciate that which is cool can do you
have a connection can I get her on the
or no I could ask yeah I could I'm not
on her favorite things list this year
cuz you know she has her holiday I know
but last year I was on the ultimate
holiday like d so when she does that
does it drive a lot of sales to you oh
yeah it's crazy the holiday one is the
one that's the one that it's the
favorite thing that's what's called the
favorite things so when when we're
talking how much sales it how much
traffic does it drive to your website in
terms of like a normal day
well I don't know but I know that on
Friday there was a lot of traffic from
H3 so I can say that I can say that too
well I don't think you said it was
really good we were I was being I was
being silly uh I was being harsh in a
silly non-serious way I didn't I didn't
take it like that at all I thought it
was really good you loved it and I knew
that I would come here today and you
guys would love it it's different then I
think they're very different it is very
different it is very
different um but there was a there was a
lot of traffic from h I think there was
more traffic from H3 than some of Thea
celebrity I I don't want to say that I
want to be on favorite things next year
Well compare to today well I'm going to
see right now cuz I have my Shopify you
want to be on my favorite I have my I do
want to be on your favorite things can't
can the chest be oh yeah that was the
Shopify
sound yeah oh I was like is that my I
have it on I'm working on my own Weight
Watchers and I'll put points on
these I'll include them you should you
definitely they've been in Health
Magazine the chocolate really yeah yeah
for being low cal you were talking about
the calories low calorie for chocolate I
mean that's not going to be low calorie
cuz that's a yeah that's a cere filled
with cereal 500 calories almost yeah but
but I mean it's a bar of chocolate what
do you want but chocolate has healthy
calories like avocado avocado has a lot
of calories but it's from the fat it's
from the cocoa butter so if you're
looking to healthily consumed chocolate
you want to be eating dark chocolate
right yes the the LA time says you
should eat 4 ounces of dark chocolate a
day 4 ounces how much is that that's
like uh a bar a bold chocolate full
chocolate bar yeah dude they're crazy
that you huh did you write that no I did
I didn't sponsored by
kartes that's crazy a full bar that's a
lot of CH but that's like telling them
pure that's pure dark chocolate right
without all the extra stuff that's less
healthy like caramel has the sugar and
stuff like that and peanut butter um you
hear that guys a whole ass bar of
chocolate and the and you know what's
cool about the bars though honestly is
because like $9.95 for a chocolate bar
some people might think that's more than
like a grocery store but it's also like
very it's like a luxury that everyone
can get right it's like you don't have
to spend $80 on a box of chocolate you
could get a bar for a friend or two you
could bring it to their house yeah for
dinner 10 bucks is not bad I got a
message from the devil where behind but
if my little Jay Peterson is Skull
Knight mura is getting extra
punishment is that a is that a league
reference what was what it
says J Jay Peterson is Skull Knight is
that I need Dan here to explain that he
needs to decode that for me oh
bring out a feasable you know about Mr
BEAST's chocolate I have never tried it
are you going to make me try it yes
I knew that would happen I said this
morning they're going to make me try Mr
Beast now hold on what give him the no
no no not that one give him the original
oh it's only one I'll see I I did see
this in the grocery store the other day
it's cheap it's like two bucks yeah it's
what do you think about how's that how
can they make a bar of chocolate and
still profit in a meaningful way if it's
$2 you know what I'm going to I've like
never seen i' I've seen it but I've
never picked it up because that's
something about me is I don't like to
taste other people's stuff I like to
just like really I love my I like you
don't get inspired by other
chocolateers I don't like to look at
what anyone's doing yeah I stay in my
Lane I do what I want and that's it oh I
we have two try the original one and you
know what I'm looking on the back to see
what's in it because a lot of times when
you get chocolate at the grocery store
it has a bunch of in it sure
interestingly this doesn't have a lot of
in it so that's kind I think that's
one of the main appeals is the
Simplicity of the
ingredients and doesn't he give away
like all kinds of prizes and yeah that's
the Beast he's a saint he's it's hard to
open hard to open right it's not as easy
compartes has a nice foldable like yeah
so and be be brutally honest we have no
allegiances can I smell it too like
absolutely take your time when you want
the cocoa you have to like smell it do
the whole experience take your
time share and devour
okay this is really go
ahead he's
chewing he looks amused uh what's your
experience
like H I think it's boring right it's
two bucks
though it tastes like it's two bucks to
me yeah it tastes like a $2 it doesn't
taste special at all it tastes like a
Hershey bu2 bar better than that I mean
why buy this buy you could buy Hershey's
there's not really oh you think Hershey
is better I I'm not I yeah I like her
Hershey's kiss I think this tastes like
a Hershey's Kiss okay like I also like
Reese's Peanut Butter Cups I like I love
Kit Kat this doesn't taste yeah Kit Kat
is so good this doesn't taste very
special to me so on a not scale of 1 to
10 10 being compartes
obviously compartes chocolate box I
would give this like a three to four oh
there it is from chocolate here's mouth
to God's ears yeah it's just kind of a
bit me and I would expect something
better from Mr Beast I find me too well
have you heard of Beast Burger I've
heard about what happened with Beast
Burger yeah but I find it to be like too
sweet it's almost like they
overcompensate with sugar there's also
nothing left in my mouth and one thing
about chocolate that they talk about is
called mouth feel which is that cocoa
butter so the mouth feel is so important
yeah this mouth feel is kind of like
non-existent waxy yeah boring it's gone
away
um I have noticed that sometimes
when I eat chocolate it's like it it
melds with my mouth so perfectly in the
texture and then sometimes when you eat
when I eat chocolate it like it's almost
like oil and oil and uh water it's like
there's not there's not mixing it feels
waxy and the texture is not good it also
forces you to eat more of it because
you're not satiated but like with good
chocolate it stays in your mouth for a
longer time and then you what the
difference in terms of I mean like I'm
going to just try my own compartes
peanut butter far but also like I'm just
going to look at the shininess too and
the color I don't think you could see
but they they even look different
different the two milk chocolates are
you totally chocolated out I'm up
right now yeah I'm absolutely
up it tastes totally different as it
when you're making the chocolate how do
you affect that mouth
feel texture it's the quality of the
ingredients just quality th% I see it's
like probably a pizza
from Pizza Hut versus like a high-end
Pizza they're using better Tomatoes
better cheese better dough maybe better
ingredients better ingredient I mean
that's really what it is what it comes
down to at the end of the day every
chocolate company is just a chef mixing
ingredients together mixing this and
that so it's like you just if you use
the best ingredients hopefully you'll
have the best product there it is pizza
is actually very nutritious I don't know
if you know that I like pizza you could
say the same thing I did a pizza bar
once oh what was it like mhm a pizza
flavors or did just shaped like a pizza
no it was pizza flavored it was white
chocolate and had caramelized pizza
crust and olive oil and I had like
sundried tomatoes and basil on it oh
whatever happened I wanted to ask you
about the cheese and the Vita yeah was
that was that a disaster if if you pull
it up you can it's like all over the
Internet let me see it broke the
internet so people were not liking it
some people liked it some people didn't
um how do you spell I mean it was filled
with vita so it was like if you like
Vita you would like it
Vita oh yeah you you can see the photo
right it's like I made it the shape of a
pasta and that sold out in like two days
too it was like crazy on the on the
website oh you linked it yeah let me
[Music]
see let's see here there it is that's
that's from our Instagram oh yeah it's
sold out on the website there it is the
people have spoken click on that one oh
that looks pretty vile but it's not your
fault obviously did you like I thought
it was interesting it was like white
chocolate and Vita so your fault I yeah
but it was cool it is cool I see I mean
people like the novelty stuff I see that
in my business too whenever we do kind
of novelty products people love it and
also it's like the drop right it's like
people want something new and different
and they taste something from compartes
that's limited edition and then they
come oh yeah that's our let's let's see
about okay did you write this no I did
not our marketing say uh I I'm not sure
read
this I see my name there so probably not
for a while I don't like reading about
I'm going to read it I'm going to read
it too step into the extraordinary world
of compartes the Avant guard destination
for chocolate Innovation and creativity
where every delectable bite transforms
you to an there's a ton of glare to an
Artful Wonderland with a legacy spanning
back to the 1950s and a contemporary
Revival led by Visionary chaer Jonathan
Graham uh-huh you didn't write that I
didn't write that part I'm not going to
read it not that it's not true I it
seems like you are a Visionary I like
what I do and I've been doing it for 25
years I really love it I'm obsessed with
chocolate seems like they did a nice
little write up for you guys though you
know there's those peanut butter cups
our imagery is really good too I think
our imagery is like really important
um so there it is
MHM do we we passed the taste test today
would you consider doing a collaboration
something like this this is a candle I
made last year dur or a few years ago do
you know what's funny what uh they asked
me to do one that's similar to that the
gwenneth palra one the gwenneth palra
one my inspiration you know the one hers
I'll tell you this hers smelled like
flowers and I guess that was the point
mhm mine smells like ass and that is
something that she dared not not do do
you guys have one here to smell do we
have one dude they're they were they
were so so good really people were
clamoring for smells like my butthole
candle I don't know how that would
translate as a chocolate flavor though
well let's try it I mean you did Vita
why not butthole butthole chocolate oh
yeah I didn't do the Gwen VRA one you
said no I said no because I thought it
would offend people a bit I mean that
but that's fair Gina it's a private you
know it's a private part vagina yeah
what was what's hers called my vagina so
would it be this taste like I think
that's what mine was supposed to be yeah
I mean we got really that is quite a
jump yeah we got really far we got
almost to the end with it and then we
didn't end up making it what were the
flavors oh so sorry I don't remember
what that was supposed to taste like but
there was definitely flavor I don't
remember I think I blocked it out but
there there was supposed to be something
something with rose right yeah I'm
looking at one that smells like it
tastes like you know the space between
your balls and after a long day
of walking
go if we can capture that in chocolate
form I think that would sell out really
fast we' sell thousands in a day on the
drop it tastes like my
butthole it it has a nice for some some
people do like to eat ass it is kind of
a phenomenon that's happening today so
like maybe it be taste like my SED and
freshly cleaned butle so it's appetizing
still to some not all but to some I
think when it comes to taste it's a very
interesting I think a
smell is like easier than taste maybe
right smell is easier than taste like I
think it's easier to yes exactly yeah
yeah I know what you
mean
I I'm just trying to think about that
and I'm like I'm an ideas man I'm just
you know Shar I share these with you you
guys what about the teddy fresh logo
because you know something we do a lot
is custom chocolate like we put logos on
them so we do like a lot of different
brands what does a Teddy fresh logo look
like it's just a it's like aedd
silhouette yeah here I'll show you cuz
we could put logos on the chocolate like
that would be cool with different color
of flab yeah different color Teddy fresh
we do Nike chocolates we do James
Charles is number one for Teddy fresh
Teddy fresh logo it's this basically
this you know silhouette oh that's cool
mhm yeah we could do that on the
chocolate just like we printed the
colors on there fun yeah we do a lot
like that I don't know that it could
taste like I'd rather put a teddy bear
on it than make it taste like a butthole
well if we're collabing we kind of got
to Quick full got to do both got to do
both it's not much of a collab if you're
not taking my input that's true I will
take your input by the way Dan were we
able to contact the candle guy to get
more for the holidays no there wasn't
enough time but but do you have his
contact yeah yeah but I want to order
more okay we need more okay I still
haven't smelled it I I think I
personally think it's a yearr round gift
yeah yeah I mean there's no season for
that right it's always in SE always time
butthole is always in season
well that's fantastic thank you so much
thank you guys thank you for having me
chocolate here and part uh compart days
people are asking for a code I don't
know if you want yeah I would love to do
a code absolutely I'm I'm going to
activated right now on my phone what
kind of discount are we talking 15% off
that's the best on the internet that's
the best that's better than like raketen
15 15 you you've got a tighter margin
than that come on hand Chate bars let me
it'll be a surprise code H3 loves
compartes can that be the code let's do
30 that's pushing it I listen 30 goes
out of business let me see wait look I'm
just advocating for my fans 3
3 oh how can you oh this just the people
on your site that's awesome 6 620 people
hi H3 and how many do you usually have
just in the middle of a a normal like 50
50 yeah nice oh wow and I'm seeing a lot
of orders coming okay well then you know
what I'm saying I'm putting the discount
hold on I'm going to activate it right
now can we just do you guys want to try
this wait hold on while I acate what's
the discount I'm going to activate let
me see what I can do 3 you're the owner
you've been on and on about how you're
the sole owner and you can't hook my
people up I'm definitely hooking your
people up 30% man
25 no 30 no 30
30 I feel like I'm at a family
dinner you know I'm advocating for my
people 30 that's that's my job here I
don't benefit from this you know what I
mean
you're what's your margin if you do 30
is that like your margin yeah it's
killing you what does that mean that
you're what does it mean it's killing
you are you losing money at 30 yeah
probably I don't I don't play with
spreadsheets I you know what do you know
what your margin is no I just know you
have a business person who calculates
all that like a accountant or
something I have an accountant who sends
me stuff at the end but I just do what I
like yeah as long as I could live and
you know that the money is positive yes
most most of the time in the summer it's
hard because like people don't buy
chocolate in the summer no why cuz it
will melt and and they're not thinking
chocolate is like a gift right so now
we're in gifting season but in the
summer you're buying ice cream or you're
like wanting lighter things that's so
true I hate when the chocolate melts in
the summer it's like we do have a no
melt guarantee even in the summer on
let's do I'm I'm trying to put this
discount a thousand visitors right now
I'm getting they're waiting for the
they're waiting for the discount I'm try
I'm on the spot and now I press I don't
even know how to turn it on on my phone
can I call my office and ask them to
make the discount 30 whatever you need
to do yeah to get the discount on hold
on I want I want the best for my folks
out there I I always advocate for them
people are going don't push listen I get
nothing I'm I'm here for you guys like
15 is great this guy's about to sell a
whole lot of chocolate okay I don't know
how to make the discount on my phone
here we go select discount type here we
go okay tell me the number you're typing
okay you typ that it doesn't allow me to
do 30 but let's see what it allows me to
do oh really yeah are your what program
are you using
Shopify my business is on Shopify
too oh God
3 I also want to do a giveaway we have a
chocolate of the month club oh fun and I
was thinking to give away one year a
Year's worth one year one like what your
dad gets yeah like my but he gets it
forever I would have one year one year
um and I'm not a big Instagram but I
know that we have their compartes
Instagram at compartes so I will do the
same thing I'll put up my post or
whatever we're going to need a 30%
discount or or I'm going to cut this
whole
part the whole thing is being cut out
for the people people are commenting you
know what they're saying 15 is fine
don't listen to Ethan I swear to God
okay first of all I don't know how many
people in the chat room but I do know
you have 30 or something
employees what are you typing I'm
putting I'm putting H3 love compart H3
loves compartes as the discount code
yeah which is true
the number is 20% that's I've never done
that ever ever 25 25 no I can't do 25
25 it's like is so amazing okay okay
okay 20 2 it was 15 you've got me to 20
oh my God people said somebody just said
18 it's like um no don't listen to them
it's like an auction right it's one of
those auctions 21 21 give me that one
dat let's do it we'll close it 20 is big
20 and it's going to be this week only
till Friday
okay I'm cutting it out
youut it hold on how do I don't know how
to do it you see I'm getting so nervous
I'm going to up the discount code
we're going to ruin can we can
we eat some more CH can we like or why
don't look at this people be like we're
losing money my employees are all going
to revolt this Advent calendar is almost
sold out too by the way like can I just
show this because like yeah this is so
cool if you Google Advent calendars
we're on the top of every Roundup
because of this amazing gorgeous and do
you design all these yourself that's
incredible I I love it that is
impressive look at how can you open one
yeah do you want to open sure I'm Jewish
so I don't really I I am too but but we
we love our Christian brothers and
sisters and especially the ones that
money yeah but like so you push the
little
thing
no spoilers hey oh oh
[Music]
wa that is honey lavender oh that
sounds good you seem kind of iffy on
that cuz I thought what if you don't
like lavender cuz you don't like jelly I
don't like jelly either but I I like
lavender I love lavender okay let's see
my body says don't eat it but my but I
do want to so I'm going
to M there also lavender color
mhm M I love lavender this is the whole
theme the whole theme of that collection
is like a garden so every flavor has
different kind of like floral herbaceous
yeah all
different all right
21 yeah I'm putting it in two
one 21 it's 1% 21 you got it
21 but let's let's find our Instagram
too and our Tik to maybe I want to see
if we beat Oprah I also did a Kendall
Jenner collaboration I want to see
what's the sales H3 versus Kendall
Jenner let's see who we need to
take we don't need to gamey um yes we do
we're going to win listen I I know we're
going to win trust me these people are
no they're nobody's do you understand
what I'm saying Kendall and Oprah are
literally old news posers H3 is the
future Save Discount Aller just like
okay we get it with the cauliflower
crust and
like I know she's eating Compares
give me a break I know she ain't eating
no cauliflower
chocolates and to be clear not a joke
about her weight I just want to make
that clear oh I didn't even put that
together I just want to I just want to
put that out there yeah yeah we're I'm
not joking about her weight just that
it's good and cauliflower pizza is not
right thank you cauliflower pizza that
doesn't sound very good that's her whole
thing oh really that's the whole Weight
Watchers and compartes for dessert okay
little giving take discount created 211%
21% baby 21 what is the code you tell
them the code is H3 loves compartes nice
21 pretty wordy maybe just
H3 I like that they love compart words
though I mean they don't know yet but I
Sam loves compartes that's true that's
true and and Ethan loves compartes yeah
I love compartes I love compartes so um
well well this is great thank you so
much thank you guys people are stoked on
the 21% I advocating for you guys always
H3 thank you for that nice deal for the
fans yeah it's my pleasure let us know
buy all your Christmas stuff now cuz it
sells out well wait till R sale then by
then yeah well spend half your money or
25% on compart 25 15 21 yeah
21% yeah don't spend all your money guys
thank you guys thank you so much farun
thank you for bringing so many yes yes
the chocolate stays
people oh thank you so much that was a
great
time and uh throw that out he
taking the Beast stuff and he's he just
slam dunked it into the
garbage dude Jonathan just said Kobe and
slamed Don Mr BEAST's chocolate on the
ground oh yeah wow spit on it spit on it
yeah yeah I saw that too I listen it's
not the best chocolate but I he's taking
it too
far dude don't stomp on it like that
chill jeez hey don't stop on it Beast
does a lot of good things all right can
somebody can somebody get him out of
here he just built a bunch of Wells
Man some violent it's not I get it the
chocolate's not that good but you to
like suplex it dude why you
taking your pants down oh don't on
the chocolate you don't have
to that that is too
far that is dude what are you
doing oh that was great wow there's so
much chocolate oh my gosh good do you
guys have some floating out there or is
just everything uh bunch of chocolate
chocolate floating around everywhere I
can't eat any more chocolate man I'm so
I'm curious where all those uh caramel
freaking salt chocas went I need more of
those you wor about those salt chocolate
those salt caramel yeah I I don't know
if I had one of those no you did the
little tur one of the very first ones oh
the turtle where's the turtles at dude
dude I'm going to die I don't think I
can eat more chocolate ever my body
feels like it's too
much that's too much they're they're
floating around somewhere they're
floating
we got to divvy all this
up there it is guys it's a chatey season
if there's any other chocolateers that
want to come bring us
chocolate yo Oprah she puts anyone or no
not that they're not worthy but like how
many people are on this oist the oist is
getting pretty long I'm saying that's
what I'm saying oh oh this list is long
Mar you know what I
[Music]
mean there it is
people can't decide they love they love
uh and brothers they love compartes it's
and
Sons Compares and what did I say and
brothers and kind of works too and Sons
right and Bros oh hell yeah
brother
so if you guys want to criticize me for
being a capitalist I just got you all
21% discount don't ever say and I bought
you know what that was you that was that
was a little taste Ethan Klein the union
leader that's it I'm advocating right
for worker rights we demand 21% discount
of you stepped into the roll gracefully
you stepped up to the plate mhm you did
budge in the end but that's part of the
tactic right you really hammered over at
30 over ask right and then you meet at a
reasonable Place 2 this is what I've
learned from my time in the trade uh
unions
yeah we should make an H3 list someone
said that's true Oprah bro we're
the movers we move I've already
started making us I've bought our domain
already I'm start I started what is it
what is it yeah Ethan's fave things is
it's Oprah's olis website URL we should
parody that it's too late now well well
let's see Oprah should bottom saying
that Oprah's o list it's actually not a
bad idea we should make our own o list
oh it's just a Sub sub page on uh daily
oist we put it on Ryan Kavanaugh the
O go to uh does does Ry Harvey Weinstein
look like ryan.com oist eist oh okay
that's better no I'm kidding we should
should we put it there cuz I think it
could actually be a legit project I
could set it up with like tracking links
and all that stuff and would could
probably actually do a good thing we
need yeah let's do yours what was yours
uh Ethan's fave things favorite was
taken already so maybe fave things my
friend by next year we'll be a
juggernaut oh
yeah that was
fun oh man I wish um another popular um
YouTuber had called in in the middle of
that though that would have been
cool just it kind like he got too much
attention I had to he needed to sit
there I mean like that it was just like
with the last guy it that was such a
Twist to go from talking about chocolate
to having Minecraft speedrun uh world
record holder dream call in next time
yeah we'll be ready do we have any
sexual degenerates calling in after yeah
like C man the eist baby it's happening
the
eist so um we talked about Brett
Cooper
we we got to talk about uh Jimmy and we
also Bor Apes one yeah I mean that's a
great story real good hold it
hold it so the Jimmy Lee documentary is
out and people are shedding
tears in fact Sam and Olivia both
admitted uh to
crying just admit I didn't cried right
here this morning I look over at her I'm
like what's wrong with you she goes so
beautiful I liter I couldn't keep it in
like there was I was watching it and you
know when your body just like can't be
quiet like everybody was doing their
little their little tasks in the morning
and I just went like and like was crying
because it was so be I just wasn't
expecting it I think the filmmaker did
an incredible Alex did an incredible job
so I don't know anything about this guy
Alex noville but this was a really good
well put together project it was really
nice I frankly I wanted more I mean it's
an hour 16 I wanted more Jimmy mhm but
it's so interesting to see him like in
his natural habitat like look how normal
he looks when he's doing
Keith come on this is a tongue and cheek
job he does get
a I'm work with me work with me he says
to the to the
tooth so funny work with me wait hold on
it it gets better it gets
better say work with me Chris but the
hookers are different they say jerk with
me it's a whole different Jimmy that is
so inappropriate while someone is like
trapped in your chair is he just doing
this because the camera's on him it has
to be right he has repeatedly emphasized
to us that he keeps it separate from
like he's serious when he's doing the
Dentistry well so there was one shot of
him being like a normal dentist here
this this stuff's great going to be a
wild though cuz I have to do the front
desk now there's nobody here so I'm
doing this so we get delayed another
five why is every dentist office look
the same what is going on here why is
this the best way we've learned to do
this since like 1980 this is what we've
got yeah okay computers we have
computers now it's a nightmare a lot of
these old offices if they started that
way it's so hard to transfer everything
my uncle bought an office and he had to
keep these he hated these files and like
transfering them took like a team of so
many people and it took like six months
I guess Dam oh that's true I guess and
Jim's been
around he's old school I keep physical
files it's old school work with me
minutes now cuz up to do a claim like
you you you count on people and you give
all the love this man can prescribe
medicine let that sink in yikes in the
years and now you're 60 or close to 60
and somebody shs it right Jimmy stop he
goes now I'm close to 60 come on Jimbo
so here look how professional stay like
that stay like
that he must be a good dentist me he's
been very
successful come on this is a tongue and
cheek job then it gets inappropriate
here kind of goes off the you're going
to say that I'm work with me I mean I
think I'd trust them more than anybody
for a root canal or some you would
yeah i' i' I'd trust him like if I
needed some serious dental work I i'
think I'd go to him not not that I don't
believe in him but based on what he's
been doing it for what 40 years
yeah he yeah and I trust
him you said what I don't trust his
comedy but I trust his Dentistry well
that would actually be fun to do a
segment if anyone needs teeth workk to
send him out there and record it my
tooth just cracked yesterday yeah where
which tooth my all the way way in the
back it just I woke up I was I was
eating pancakes the softest thing ever
pancakes yeah and I noticed something
crunchy was in there and I was like oh
no oh part of my tooth is missing
so is that something that you need to
fix yeah I've I've had it fixed a few
times but it keeps just cracking they
put like a half fake tooth all the way
in back let's see if Jimmy can help
would you fly out to New Jersey fly out
to Jersey I mean I'll pay for the flight
yeah I do it if Ian goes with
me I haven't seen a dentist in 10 years
okay that's pretty long time why am I
why am I getting roped into this
probably a good idea to check I want to
say anything I I just thought I had fun
with you I when I went when we did the
crypto thing so spend some time with you
Ian's a good asset
together you want to bring who with
you wa it sounded like maybe cam should
go if he hasn't been to the dentist uh
yeah I mean that's that's a good
narrative Cam's first dentist visit in
10 years which God oh got a good wait
that would be really good he's going to
Tim Watley your ass Kim oh I already
know that but cam you up for a visit to
New Jersey sure I love the East Coast
yeah you probably because well if goes
St by home real quick too can Ian come
with me Ian you got to go sorry bro
everyone uh oh Ian doesn't want to go
he's nervous he's oh oh no thank you for
tell I know how to feel and that's
Comfort yeah you're
welcome uh but actually one of the more
interesting Parts too
was his uh orbiters these there's two
people in general that like work with
him pro bono really closely and uh
they're real interesting characters too
see I always say work with me Chris but
the hookers are different they say jerk
with me it's a whole different
experience with them you got to be
Legacy one people and he did a reaction
video and then and I contacted
them pal oh come watch I know it is now
come this way I have thanks to H3 and
Ethan because I don't think I would be
where I'm at without him Jimmy Lee has a
special he's why did that happen it just
closed it for no
reason that's it that's the dock wrap it
up people see you
everybody so Andrew should be here soon
and I'm Andrew go wait so where is
this
then this is the part that see youor
mom's brain to make people the the
brother storyline was so interesting to
me cuz we can talk about it when here
here number
11 is the one that got me here's Jimmy's
and they actually so he's for many years
strange from his brother real quick his
hair looks so much better in that frame
no no no no no no no if you go back like
where it's kind of longer and he's got
the keep on top but it it looked so much
better this no no no when he was in the
dentist office oh like normal like
normal it looks it looks way better well
so here's his brother that looks just
like him but he just you know he just
bicked the Dome and it looks good right
yeah Jimmy would probably be benefited
from that but anyway Jimmy told us he's
been aranged from his brother for so
long but this this documentarian got a
hold of his brother to interview for the
show it's pretty interesting the
documentary writer and I work with a
music producer and couldn't get famous
doing something I'm taled at and
something I'm goofy at I get noticed for
when you figure out entertainment let me
know the opposite happened for me I'm
just being honest because I've been
doing music since I was a kid you know
he was playing the piano he was playing
the guitar I remember that in our
bedroom we shared a bedroom for many
years we both grew up in the same house
and I ended up being a nice guy and he
ended up being a caniver and a bad guy
I'm a good guy jeez and I thought it was
so beautiful the way Alex put it
together the whole movie you have these
cuts to his brother saying like lovely
things about him and like we knew that
Jimmy was a stranged from him but you
didn't when you watch it so this moment
I thought was really it hit me so hard
Olivia goes I miss my sister I said I'm
going to text
Alex Jimmy was a cute kid he was he is
opposite of me and my wife always says
how did two guys grow up the same and be
so different I don't know you know I
know Jim said to you that we you know we
kind of went our own ways and we're very
different of course we're we're very
different and some may ask well how can
you be so different if you grew up in
the same family well it it happens you
know what Sav Warfare is Rickles or
Sinatra can walk into a room they say
the right things they know what to do
you don't have to say anything to them
my brother just doesn't have that he
wasn't that's an interesting
criticism listen my brother he doesn't
have that J uh janua Frank Sinatra and
such he's a
dork other words person he never
was and he never will be and he puts on
a nice act like and he acts nice but
stuff he's done is so bad I couldn't
imagine in my worst dream doing things
like that and once my dad died that was
pretty much it that's it Jim and my
father at the time of his death you know
I don't know they didn't have the
closest
relationship and I'm not sure that they
were able to talk about these these
matters my father unfortunately
didn't get a a lot of time with Jim and
his family before he he died that was
kind of less draw when dad died in the
way Larry handled things Larry is is
greedy and he's not a good guy so it's
okay cuz you see I'm not upset with him
but I won't bother with him I don't get
upset I just don't bother with you CU
I'm older and I don't have that much
time to live and I got to get famous so
the L thing I need to do is bother with
you cuz you're not a nice guy you know I
personally hope for the day that we
could be closer we hope for the day that
we get to meet his kids I mean I've
never met his children that's sad you
know that's that's the you know the
situation I make people feel good
whether I do comedy whether I'm nice to
people in the office and that's the
problem with Larry he doesn't make you
feel good you it makes you feel bad and
you know he's conniving something and
he's going to screw you over and not be
a good guy and I'm done Jim and I we
have had significant loss
my parents didn't treat Jim
good he's got to forgive them people
change so I I don't know what happens
and they grow a p he asked me to you
know not talk about details of this and
that and I said Jim I respect that like
even my wife said Larry why do you even
want to do this well selfishly I think I
want to do it and I've done it is
because I have a feeling that it's
another possibility of reconnecting us I
just feel that what a
way to end this film with some type of
like
reconciliation or reconnection with a
sibling we're brothers and I want to be
closer to my
brother and I'm hoping through this this
film that maybe there's a chance that
can happen because we are are running
out of time gim so um let's figure this
out family family family
family point to the hairline
Anna the hairline strong I have been
very driven and I'm an older guy not old
old but older middle Ag and I got to
keep no Jim you are Jim I guess start
calling him Jim no I have't run out of
they got me at the same time we got to
we got to get them talking I I did has
Jimmy ever said what his brother did
that was so hor sound pretty bad they
talked about like earlier in the dock
they revealed that um Jimmy's mom had a
bipolar and she killed herself yeah and
I'm like crying so much G I love Jimmy
yeah I I like Jimmy too a lot and I I he
probably has valid reasons is my I'm I
mean I know it's none of my business but
I'm curious gez
Louise but
um I guess there's some things that you
know you can't forgive people
for there are
some but I don't
know there was a part earlier I remember
seeing where his brother was talking
about
how Jimmy was the youngest and that he
got the worst from his parents I don't
it sounds like a wild
uh a really horrible upbringing where
like his parents like the older brother
but hate the younger brother like
Jesus apparently he had like he was like
hyperactive maybe that was part of the
problem he couldn't sit still he's
histrionic
um let's see anyway now that
we've now that we've got the tearjerker
part here's a racist compilation oh my
God you look like in Jewish yish you're
a shika what are you Spanish I'm Ty Ty
the thing he was doing in this
documentary that consistently blew my
mind he goes up to every Asian girl he
passes by and he says Hey China Doll oh
my God it's so
crazy Southeast Asian uh person yikes
yeah it's really bad my my wife's
Chinese so I think you got good taste so
you know my funny shook when I see an
Asian guy my funny J we got we got
dinner may I I am the comedian you know
my funniest joke when I see an Asian guy
come I asked him if he has any Duck
Sauce are you Indian honey yes what's
your day say I'm going to guess Patel
I'm only teasing here does the Red Dot
the Red Dot signify you're of Indian
faith and she said no no I've been shot
call 911
[Laughter]
oh he crushed it with that one though
her husband was vibing on that one je
was old timey humor the husband's all
about that old time that was a fat dub
let me see your
papers what are you I'm Mexican oh
that's better likes to approach
everybody it doesn't matter who it is he
sometimes goes for the jugular because
that's his comedy he has a whole lot of
uh
a whole lot of uh you know um Asian
jokes Le got how do I put this uh he has
a lot of uh this man he's really doing
the Tim Watley that he's like married to
a Chinese woman and so he's got the
blank check for any Asian jokes you can
imagine China Doll hey don't worry I'm
married to a Chinese broad hey I'm
hungry now hey I'm H when every time I
see her I get hungry yeah hey sometimes
she's on her knees but what's that one
he says about the knees all the time uh
but next Thursday she'll be on her knees
that's what he says it just it rhymes
with Chinese yeah I don't remember to
say it Rhymes I had a hooker you know I
dropped my pant she dropped the price
hey work with me work with me Bingo but
again that joke is backwards she should
raise the price when she
sees because she doesn't want to have
sex with him if she's lowering the price
it means she wants to have sex with him
right right although I know what he's
saying is that maybe his small I think
you pointed this out to him yeah did was
he receptive well about as receptive as
he usually is he didn't fix it it's like
an easier task so like exactly yeah I
don't
know fever the yell fever go
Asian go Asian dude what the so he went
to Chinatown
I mean this man is he he really truly is
a ying-yang of a man isn't he like
nobody encapsulates the human spirit
it's quite like Jimmy Lee he is he's
great you you struck gold with
him all these years too you know all
these years we're still close yeah I do
think that like and I think a lot of you
agree there is a genuine affection
that's grown between us oh yeah
yeah you disagree Dan even you have to
agree to some
extent he is an I don't disagree with
what you just said what what do you then
what was it the Chinese I don't know I I
don't yeah just all of it I don't know
you know I'm not as hot on uh
Jimmy I kind of had a heated moment
about Jim this morning so why what
happened just there's a lot of back and
forth with was scheduling things for him
and it just are you still working out
the Bobby Lee thing well it didn't work
out it didn't I confirmed with him six
times that he didn't want to do it oh
he's not doing it and then he comes back
to me yesterday he's like hey I'm coming
to La can I get on Bobby and he the
dates he gave me were the the dates I
told him Zach drop it it's not your
responsibility well that's what
I keep he had his chance and he
it up that's what I'm saying that's what
I keep um telling him but it something's
not getting it's J Dude Z you got with
Jimmy you have to stop responding yeah
it's what it's what I'm doing good and
he doesn't get it like it's all the back
and forth it's like I
I'm with peace and love to Jimmy it's
already a favor that Bobby was willing
to have him come on I reached out to
Bobby and asked him for a personal
favor exactly and one of the
biggest pod comedy podcasts in the world
yeah and I'm friendly with his producer
and so like it's embarrassing to just
like have to like go back and forth it's
just like I told him no foret no he's
he's lost the the chance yeah I told him
no Moss he I mean the ship is sailed
it's just so crazy he does so much he'll
do anything to get any kind of attention
any kind of media Bobby Lee invites him
on a show I was ready to throw my
this morning I was so pissed
dude well it sucks because I actually
really wanted to watch that I there's
something that there's a disconnect that
he just is not getting and I tried to
tell him is it possible he's scared of
Bobby I just don't think he wants to
spend the cheddar to come out here but
then he like comes back but he spends
like $20,000 every weekend with like
well I think here's what happened I
think this was we told him this before
the documentary came out so now I think
he's got this Mr Hollywood thing
where he's like oh I need to go out to
LA it's got 4,000 views by the way to
promote the documentary so now he's like
I'm coming I'm spending I'm Mr Bing Bang
Boom you know I see so I think he get
he's getting his you know he's getting
the gears winding if there's an easy way
to just say hey he's in town does this
work and then that's it I'd be okay with
that but I'm also okay with you not if
you guys being totally over it the dates
he gave me is when they're not filming
so then you know what the
yeah God I I'm selfishly just really
want to watch that which I told him six
times
maybe we can come around it it the
scheduling was difficult because of the
holidays that was part of the issue wait
I have an idea maybe we can do it next
hold on I have an idea maybe we can get
them both in this studio cuz I feel like
that would be easier to coordinate well
Jim's coming out early
December they won't that's not going to
work why just because I know their
schedule and oh he's out of town
yeah that would be fun 2024 we'll we'll
get the the Jimmy Bobby 2024 is is the
year I think it's j for now
damn it is really fun though it's a it's
a nice watch it's interesting but this
this part is hello love what is your
name I'm Chinese Chinese it's pretty
lady Chinese or Korean love Chinese very
pretty Hong Kong Chinese or Hong Kong
Chinese a pretty lady a Chinese correct
oh yes correct well done well Hong Kong
Chinese yeah are you guys Hong Kong
Chinese or we're not Chinese Japanese
Japanese but your husband's American cuz
you're beautiful ladies and you look
like you're mixed oh my God they're not
even jokes they're just super weird
comments I'm sorry but I can't stop
thinking about him saying my brother's
so mean he makes people feel bad and
then like this needs to be overlaid
after that like listen it's part of the
beauty of Jimmy Lee's complex psyche
it's he's like I'm not like that he
thinks taking people out to dinner and
paying for it is him being a good guy he
thinks him paying them a salary yeah
he's like I don't pay him I just
buy him some salami G buy him a plate of
cold cuts at the end of the day kabish
take them out to pinks treat them real
nice you like a corn dog treat yourself
introduce them to Mr Pink or I mean you
like a uh what do you call it the sloppy
sloppy joke why can't I remember chil
dog yeah you want a chili dog treat
yourself hey on the house I got it I got
I'll cover the chili pinks loves Jimmy
Lee
pretty Chinese girl and rich Japanese
and rich Japanese man how you doing
china doll how you doing all right
married Fed Up married you're married no
a he seems to genuinely have uh problem
fetish for for uh Asian women I don't it
seems that like he'll talk to anyone but
every time he sees an Asian woman it's
like hey beautiful woman you from Hong
Kong are you mixed it's it's his tagline
bring him Asian uh always Asian never
Caucasian that's what he always says
Hey a rich white guy let's get let's go
right now I want two I want two Japanese
women just in case of one of let man I
have to have two okay which one's going
to be my main one and which one's my
side one you want to be the E
dude by the way I spoke with his wife on
the phone uh you did few months back
like we did like a group call like I got
to add her to the phone call I got to
add her to the call and she was very
nice she's got to be cuz his kids are
like normal as his boys are normal
and when he's like out of this mode he
is relatively normal that's what the kid
his kid said he's like just a nice guy
but when he gets in this Dr Jack
we like a nice guy not a funny guy right
his wife was very nice she was very
appreciative of everything man how did
he settle down with anyone I mean
he wow main one or you be the main one
which is my main wife which is my second
wife M main wife you're second M all
right I got a lot of money too you can
buy Sho handbag you want Cho handbag sh
handbag dude this is not a joke he's
trying to pick them up yeah and he's
holding them again so this is the this
is the dichotomy of Jimmy we were crying
about his tragic
backstory we were
sobbing and now he I'm thinking he
should be in
prison I think both can be true yeah
that's the beauty of it both can be true
he makes it so hard to like
him my job is now to just get big and
viral and be on the street all the time
and pound social media so I'm bigger so
people come to me cuz when they come to
me are interested through my whole
career of Dentistry I always wanted to
do it but now I'm just doing it cuz I'm
older and I have less time when you're
young you have a lot of time and no
money when you're older like me you have
a lot of money you have limited time so
now I got to go we got to find some
people it's pretty fun I was confused by
this mozzarella guy though where I I
looked away for a second and then I was
like what am I watching oh my God he
reminds me so much of my mom's family
it's crazy it was the guy's
interesting but I didn't know what the
I was watching I like the fact he's
living his dream you get you get it to a
point in life you just want to this
turns into like a whole 30 minute
segment about this guy making mozzarella
cheese the mozzarella boss he is funny
have your goals and you want to
accomplish your dreams he's he's the
Jersey Outlaw I'm the mozzarella boss
hey everyone my name's Rob Nestor I'm
the mozzarella boss out of South Jersey
I've been a friend to Jimmy Lee to
Jersey Outlaw going back to 1985 where
we met at Harris Casino when I was
washing his uncle's boat okay two 10t
trucks mhm all
right would have been
um he makes mozzarella he's it's quite
interesting he's mozarella necessarily
need
to we don't need to dump it right on top
Jee it's I swear to God 30 minutes of
this and we'll put this back on and then
this is how it started so I would just
start making this instead of driving
amazing
right I would just start making this
over here we get some bread some
Tomatoes some tomatoes and we you know
enjoy
it wow that's the real deal when you
taste it you're going to be like wow and
everybody loves they seem to love when I
go like gu
look look at that look at that look you
can't even see
me use the force right isn't that how
you would do it Jim look use the this is
how they do it how did he do it with
Yoda so we're going to make's see if we
can make this look this is like you got
when you practice you want to practice
like Luke Skywalker you go like it's
what did he say
Ben right lay yeah that's what he say
when
he or
it's when he looked
at see I'm more like I started out like
Yoda but now I'm more like what's his
name Palpatine
look right prequel look isn't that how
would do we're looking right and you're
just you need some forc lightning can
you add that to the film a you know look
I I want
some Stars this guy is a bonafied
character like I could not look away I
think this guy just heard this was going
on the internet he's like oh those nerds
like Star Wars I'm just going to
keep bringing up Star Wars in every
sentence
he does yeah talk about I need like the
Star Wars theme music you know like
Palpatine when all the ships are rising
right can we do that yeah we can do oh
you got to make me that you you want to
make that one that's like my favorite
scene right and then he's
like
right music we welcome the CF over here
you've been holding the
mozzarella up for so long and then you
could do like one like this switching
arms we should have this guy on the
show you know he's walking like this can
we get this guy on Bobby I was about to
say cam the we should with Jimmy
and just make the mozzarella boss Super
Famous hey do you want to make
mozzarella at our live show dude yeah
it live demo live
demon Jimmy would he' kill us
he'd kill us right he's still holding it
up man are we done stretching so stretch
anyway so yeah he a pretty interesting
guy but there it is the Jimmy Lee
documentary tears cringe anger that
frame of his hair that frame of his hair
that you just closed it was like perfect
oh how do you mean it looks better than
his soon his uh uh chman M his
yeah exactly all right thank you so
there's one thing left but how we've
been going for clean yeah we're at uh
312 we started on time today mhm I
wanted to do the eel pit segment we've
been putting this together and it's
really
interesting but uh which segment eel pit
the eel pit one the oh right right right
right well it's a it's Evergreen we can
get to it some other time today's what
Monday do it on do on Wednesday yeah
it's a good Wednesday segment F so we'll
do pit on
Wednesday the other one I wanted to
watch was the board Apes people being
blinded but I guess that one's that kind
of Wednesday worthy we can talk
Wednesday too
yeah you say you want to do it now I
said we could talk about on Wednesday
but it's pretty quick just knock it out
so board 8
party you know board 8 Club as you many
of you will remember it was like a a
really popular sucess successful
extraordinarily expensive nft horrible
art dumb art of monkeys
wearing this yeah thank you this this
was selling for six digits at least
this one is very relevant
now true like I don't know what they're
worth now I think they're still somewhat
valuable I think they're the only one of
these that still is somewhat valuable
let's see uh just can't I don't think
they're ready to accept that they spent
hundreds of thousands of dollars on a
worthless terrible
art like the even the background color
is
gross like what is that green man so
depressing so this one sold for 29 eth
the floor price is
$56,000 this so they're still very
valuable yeah yeah well they were
hundreds like 300,000 or something yeah
and somewh so anyway they these guys
Yuga Labs we actually talked about them
how they're like might be secret Nazis
or something and then remember the
manager reached out and the everyone was
like trying to get me to have them in
the office and mhm well they're
blinding all their
people here's the party they had a party
just for board ape
owners here's the attendees AP Fest ape
Fest yep not a single woman in sight
someone said and that is a kind of a
good observation honestly there is
really I I I literally cannot see a
single
woman this music is definitely cover
yeah um pause it let's see well hold let
me get a better a brighter frame there
there you go there's not maybe here is
this that
one maybe I think that might be a woman
this might be a woman
Maybe way back here oh back here yeah
maybe her yeah yeah I think that's it
could be I guess I'd have to see it in
motion this is
truly a room of the biggest suckers in
the world like let's get some time share
salesman in there they'll clean
up that place oh yeah hi I mean golly
but anyway so they all came
together had a really fun special
time you'll notice it's really purple in
this room like really purple it's Good
Vibes by the way um it's interesting
they're all like kind of the same type
of person I don't know how to describe
that they're like young Tech Bros I
don't know yeah but how do they I how do
these guys have so much money to buy
this that's something I don't
understand there's a lot of like
millionaires that's like around 25 right
now just because of crypto yeah yeah
that's proba and they're all like nerd
nerds who got money and then they use
the money to like prop himself up and
super crunch so here is the
stage uh that was at the show and you'll
notice there's a intense UV lights
blasting
out uh at the
audience so everyone's just looking up
there looks fine looks nice B board ape
Yacht Club well yeah shot him down in
the crowd there you go something
actually went wrong
here it turns
out that whatever UV lights they were
using are actually super dangerous and
super damaging to the eye people started
to report in mass that they were going
blind and I'm not kidding look at
this yes Me 2 3: a.m. I woke up my eyes
were burning I could barely open them
getting a few pings on eye issues from
ape friends that were up close with us
front stage quick thread on photo
kisis and what to look out for they all
have cried the board AP and the profile
I woke up at 4 and couldn't see anymore
I had so much pain and my whole skin is
burned I need to go I needed to go to
the hospital the doctor told me the UV
of the lighting was this in the stage is
what did it has the same effect as
sunlight still cannot see
normally anyone else eyes burning from
last night I woke up at 3:00 a.m. with
extreme pain it ended up in the ER I saw
a couple reports but just trying to
figure out if there was a com in thread
so they like I mean it's up but
like
in Mass just
blinding it's crazy here look at
this here's a
attendee who's both
uh he's very I I think he's approaching
this in a really mature manner I'll read
it posting that in hope that my friend
suffering the same issue realized need
they need medical attention
ASAP thank you for a great ape Fest
logistic guys incredible event and met
plenty of amazing
people still as dozen of others I almost
lost sight this
night I'm being taken care of by doctors
now and have only good intentions
writing this
post to my friends who suffer now go get
your eyes checked you've likely most
literally got your eyes burned with UV
like I did which requires medication eye
drops eye protection and antibiotics and
Specialized Care okay
don't don't ignore this health hazard
without proper treatment it may cause
long- lasting Vision impairment and
other serious damage to the organizers
for the communication awareness reasons
it would be fair to put together an
official statement with recommendations
on what to do as dozens of people you
care about were exposed to serious
health hazards and lots of suffering
you're good guys so I know that it'll be
easy for you guys to recognize the
serious of this much love so this dude
went to a event was blasted in the
face with dangerous UV light all
night he's blinded he can't
see because of their insanely gross
negligence and he's still out here like
thanks for the great event guys you guys
really listen other than for everyone
being blinded and permanently eye
damaged it was really a great
event like holy dude brainwashed
there's got to be Mega lawsuits from
this hopefully
um here's another person posting their
hospital
bill let's see oh this is the same
guy so far 30 hours since I woke up with
severe iburn I visited the emergency
hospital in an eye clinic and spent a
total of 6 hours I got diagnosed with
photo cisis and prescribed prescription
eye drops my vision was tested as close
to perfect with no serious damage so
many my okay that's good yeah
so many of my friends are still unaware
that they may seek medical help to make
sure they end with no damage as well
please go get your eyes checked
immediately we've most likely been
exposed to experience similar to Mount
Everest climbers called snow
blindness snow blindness is caused by
unpredicted exposure of the cornea and
conjunctiva to ultraviolet light
specifically
UVB snow blindness is therefore sunburn
of the eye and can be extremely painful
well he only spent $400 on medical that
seems
cheap yeah he's in I mean he's in Hong
Kong yeah Hong Kong so wait Hong Kong
still has their own money mhm I thought
they combined not yet well not fully
it's complicated okay so yeah 380 that's
kind of a good deal actually some
friends called in ambulances for
themselves still all together not that
expensive yo call Imagine calling an
ambulance for yourself cuz you
[Music]
got so
anyway this ad for the event is poorly
worth in retrospect let's
see keep your eyes peeled at aest Hong
Kong as BMW unveils the future with
their unique interactive experience keep
your eyes peeled literally your eyes
will be peeling Mama they're already
peel have your eyes ever peeled before
well they will
today I mean that's pretty
wild
let's
see um oh they put out an official
statement okay let's see what they
said
Apes we are aware of the eye related
issues that affected some attendees of
ape Fest and have been proactively
reaching out to individuals since
yesterday based on our estimate we
believe that much less than 1% of those
attending and work in the event had
these symptoms don't worry everybody we
only permanently damaged the eyesight of
1%
much less than 1% I'm sure that's not
true that can't everyone in that room
was being blasted while nearly everyone
has indicated their symptoms have
improved we encourage anybody who feels
them to seek out medical attention this
is the final tweet in this thread we do
not want to talk about this
anymore no I think it's because uh
everybody is constantly trying to scam
each other in the crypto space that they
have to be like I see you see any rep
it's not
real what a great
Community Krypto ey they really are the
best a some great replies let's have a
look I love
these uh fix this for you that's funny
that is
good from the pr Team guys completely
downplay it make it sound like a small
number less than 1% make it look like
they're actively helping and solving try
to find the potential root cause even
though we know exactly what it was okay
okay first two look weirdly similar what
about now see yeah this is the Nazi
stuff I've been a loyal Community member
for over two years my ape is not only
the most expensive thing I own it's the
one the only things I own yikes that's
so
amazing I don't have a car I don't have
clothing I think this one's a troll I
don't know for sure but it's funny
either I had my parents give me a loan
so I could attend ape Fest and now I am
drowning in eye related medical bills I
don't know how to
pay yeah L this tweet doesn't even
include a single apology that's kind of
true they probably don't want to admit
fault they're going to get sued morons
scumbags losers
freaks all right that was it I guess
that's it
well my beautiful family thank you to to
all the members who support us
graciously every month means so much
especially because of Ben Shapiro and
his friends are obsessed with cancel
culture yep they have ruthlessly
targeted
us um but yeah thank you guys uh thanks
for watching it was a nice show I got a
lot of chocolate to
eat and uh we'll be back on
[Music]
Wednesday see members tomorrow for my
live
stream I'm thinking it's possible that
there might be a Leftovers on Thursday
I'm not 100% sure
but we'll see I'm not sure yet if I want
to go there or not there's a lot of
things that I felt like I still want to
talk about and say which is what's
making me feel like I want to do it but
on the other hand I'm thinking about
dealing with all the shitel culture yeah
yeah cancel culture exactly thank you uh
Brett
Cooper so I'm thinking about it we'll
see
anyway see you guys on Wednesday
appreciate you thanks for
[Music]
watching